[Music]
my
[Music]
so
mic check might check what's going on
around
talk to me my man hustle up in there
early stitch what's going on brother i
see you get caught around cops here
what's going on man flame it's my easy
cowboys fan what's going on talk to
people let me know how the level's just
going on six late i see you brother
what's going on thank you brother thank
you also doovey what's up
thomas with a chill out bro it ain't
that serious
pick on fusion what's going on man sorry
lois we have to change it up
last minute um we're not really changing
anything we're going back to our normal
time we were trying to give us symbols
some time
because he thought he might have to get
the kids but um he
is good we're going to be back on track
for the normal 1 p.m eastern
kay asante feed the wolves ksrt i seen
that
i like that that gator that net gator
was looking right looking crispy hustle
that that gator was looking right
the wolves was being fed i see you
double tj what's up man
yeah man sean zoo what's up what's up
good to see you spider
you know what i mean soy through monks i
think that's how we say it
hey abel asking okay you know what i'm
saying
lord nader what's up man so yeah we're
gonna get assembled in here
he's gotta i think that limited time but
we'll still rock out we still got the
topics and stuff
and then the king and everybody else
going to be pulling up they already know
attic is here talk to him i guess i
don't know anybody might be in the
budget he's still
setting up for the year yeah echo yeah
echo for me advanced gamer let me know
because everybody else said my audio was
okay
q10 clan what's up
let me know if i got an echo i need to
confirm or deny
you know what i'm saying cog id is that
serious when you block folks see the
constant argument say something about it
and mods come after you nah we're not
coming after you we just saying in
general
if someone's saying something you don't
have to go at them you know what i'm
saying
like as long as they don't direct it to
you that's all that's what we say when
you're trying to go after people
if people trolling we don't care like as
long as people
ain't disrespectful on a personal level
that's where we get crazy because it's
like
just ignore the person you already know
what the person trying to do you know
what i'm saying that's what i'm saying
thank you about the no echo y'all
um no that's it nobody trying to attack
the loyal fan base six but i i hear your
point we will try to do a better job
about it so we don't feel like we're
attacking the people
attacking the trolls if you get what i'm
saying so anyway
thank you for that feedback i do
appreciate it um we're gonna be started
soon let me get
a symbol in here and uh the rest of the
lords will pull up but uh
i'll see y'all tonight it'll be a fun
show
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable i
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame
still i'll be running collecting them
reigns you just a target when i'm in the
range i was the hardest to start
regardless back
with messaging people check my vocals
on twitter but i'm anti-social love my
city but i'm still by
[Music]
it i'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lord's
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game
just be original y'all so dramatical i
know it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame
still i'll be running collecting them
reigns you're just a target when i'm in
the range i was the hardest to started
regardless back when you was messaging
people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on the song with
me that's understandable i kill a beat
and they want to compare me to freddie
and jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game
just be original y'all so dramatical i
know it's random but i'm addicted to
flipping the sample
[Music]
i'm very spoiled for them to be your dog
thing very loyal but i ain't gonna hold
you i ain't here to boy you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lord's
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't wanna be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game
just be original y'all so dramatical i
know it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you're just a target when i'm in the
range i was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people check my vocals all on twitter
but i'm anti-social love my city but i'm
still by coastal i
[Music]
for you always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
[Music]
and watch them any snacks in the attic i
wanted to chill with the pack and be
like a young wolf but then they would
mistake me for addict if i can imagine
it's cool to give you some advice and
invite your girl to your squadron cause
if you don't give her that option you're
gonna be single player like siren you're
gonna get tossed in the bushes by king
david
royalty not a pretender detrimental to
an elemental what's the avatar to a knee
bender i gotta be me though
i know it's my destiny word to cognito
who cares if you fly if you're still a
mosquito you swear you ain't something
but really
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news
even if you really was that jew king
david still be the king of the statues
since the juvenile i've been cursed with
a curse to be musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in the crucible other than
nothing it's cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this in your cubicle
on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right hear ye hear ye and we
are live welcome to the iron lords
podcast and also live on lords of
gaming.net
episode number 201 and it's another
glorious sunday we're back at the round
table on the lord's date
i'm very excited about our very special
guest and we've got the xbox watch event
sony buying evo and square enix presents
to discuss so we gonna get right into it
i want to introduce the lord whose
content was first brought to my
attention by our late long day brother
lord dizzy not only this lord combined
genres of multi-platform gaming movies
and collecting
but is truly an ambassador for mental
health and positive community building
introducing the creating host of the
assembled youtube channel and host of
the assemble show
podcast the lord of weekly nerdy content
and drunken cigar story time about the
mcu
oh you got the cigar that's what i'm
talking about live
from the sixth and kind enough to make
his debut
at the realm of the lords mommy
lord matt aka lord assemble how we doing
sir i'm
great thanks for having me that is the
biggest intro i've ever received on
anything i don't get that when i come
home at the end of the day i
am home she's like do the dishes
do the dishes that's boy
thanks so much for having me guys i'm
excited i'm excited to be here and talk
all things xbox and
everything going on in the gaming realm
right now it's awesome absolutely man
like
your lord at what you do and i want to
again i would be remiss if i didn't give
a shout out
to my brother lord dizzy because uh he
was the one that actually found your
content and he brought it to my
attention and um
you know i was like look i gotta make it
happen i know we you've been in
communication for some time trying to
make it happen
and it was on the lord's fault cause we
had so many reschedules to do
but i'm glad we are able to get it done
so we can do
but anyway man whatever you have been
playing brother what any games you've
been playing
right now uh right now it's marvel's
avengers so because of all of the
updates and everything
go figure i am covering that a ton so
like i just did
on even on the channel i just did
yesterday the hawkeye dlc review
yeah and i got through that i had some
thoughts on that how that played out but
avengers has taken over and will for
like probably the next month
um outside of that but like on the xbox
side it's been
dabbling in to bethesda and the catalog
that's come out
and yeah looking at dishonored
going back and playing doom like just
getting my feet wet with a lot of stuff
so on the xbox side yeah it's been a lot
of bethesda right now
how do you like the um the avengers game
because i'm i have it
and i've been reluctant to go back right
now like you said playing the bethesda
stuff
um by the way love your background you
already know that you know i'm having an
eye gas
statue game yeah exactly um but
uh how how is it um besides all the
hoopla because you know
everybody wants to give the hoopla what
what's your real assessment of the
updates
uh in the game so far i think the next
gen updates if you have a series x or
ps5 i played on my ps5
and it's very welcome i think it's very
balanced the load times are quick
like five seconds to load from loading
up the game to
going like you're you're within seconds
now instead of
35 seconds in an elevator
so the load times being cut down
dramatically changes the pacing of the
game
having the extra textures having the
gameplay smoother better
frame rates at 60fps if you want it
right all those things are good quality
of life
the downside right now is the dlc for me
uh the hawkeye dlc did not land for me
oh that's what kaibatsu told me sorry
yeah it just it didn't do enough right
and i think enough people have given
feedback over the weekend too they're
like yeah i thought it was fine
and i'm like i don't really watch
people's stuff but you know i like
because i really like to eat my own food
but the fact that i do have it and then
i do have you here
uh is is it a worthwhile checkout yes
because if you haven't played it and
you're looking i'd say the campaign
especially now with all the updates
that's worth your time because you can
get a nice avengers story that's solid
kamala is a solid character
yes i that's worth your time and then go
and dabble into the online after but i
think that when you got it right now
sitting there
yeah you got all the updates and
everything right it's worth your while
to at least jump in and be like all
right i'll go through the single-player
campaign
yeah i ended the single-player campaign
i did that stuff
i did it when it was broken
so now when it's fixed i want to go in
there and do the maestro stuff i'm a
huge hulk fan so no it's okay
and you already know we got the four
horsemen of gaming those original lords
of the realm here at the round table
with those time sensitive intros because
assemble has limited time
lord added hope he's there my calls with
the call most my brother from another
mother
the difficult game conqueror lord of his
own world and the how
of the young wolf with his mic muted if
he's still there my man lord addict
he's in the bushes
[Laughter]
stepped away quickly so hopefully he'll
be back by the way what's up man
cassandra what's up
and of course we have our most technical
gaming lord the solo game on this with a
single player selfish experience
and also the softstradamus the lord of
clarity and lord patreon of the iron
bank my man
lord salford how are we doing sir i'm
doing well until addict decides to jump
in i'm like
when he comes back you know it's coming
up i'm doing good man i'm doing good uh
the sun's out
getting a little warmer you know just
get get rid of
the winter blue is a little bit you know
that's
anything even playing sir um yeah so i
didn't get a chance i wanted to jump
into avengers because i didn't play it
when it first came out and i said all
right let me just wait for these
updates to come um and i was gonna play
yesterday and of course that didn't
happen so
uh the little time that i did have i sat
down and started messing with
fps boost games and going back to so i
threw on that dishonored
okay okay oh brother what are we doing
how's it looking listen man that game
a game was always about you know kinetic
movement like especially once you get
once you get
your blink ability and you're able to to
move from enemy to enemy to enemy in it
at 60 oh
it is something else that game i can't
say it enough
if you never played dishonored
play that game that game is made for you
to break it
and when you do break it oh my god
that you know those games are amazing so
i played that
um i messed around a little bit with
fallout 4 i had to turn off because i i
had turned on the uh what's your mccall
auto issue the no well the mod the mod
60 fps right oh
right when you do that you don't get
achievements anymore so i turn that off
turn on the fbs boost and uh very nice
nice very nice
shot of the team besides that i i
watched the first hour and a half of
of justice league very good things
assembled was happening i'm hearing
listen listen i've only watched an hour
and a half and an hour and a half i've
seen
so much new footage and if you hear what
zack snyder said he's like yeah they
told me not to film anymore and i didn't
listen
and yeah it is a lot of new footage and
what it does
is it gives that movie and those
characters
context to what they're doing and back
stories
that make you care about them in a way
that again
justice league as a concept because they
weren't doing the going the mcu route
was always going to be a hard sell
because you you weren't going to be
as in love with these characters as and
intimate with these characters as they
as the mcu ones just because of how they
chose to do it this is the closest we're
ever going to get to that
right and i think it you know listen
love zach and i that zack snyder or hate
him
you know a lot of he doesn't he's not
subtle about anything right
no he's just subtle as a hammer over the
head but
this movie needed that it needed you to
be able to move from point
to point to point to point and show you
why these characters are even involved
in
this
conflict and why it matters and i think
what i've seen so far
yeah yeah great job
they did such a great job not to spoil a
thing but yeah
amount of character development yes in
that movie
is amazing and i think that was my
biggest takeaway is
you actually get to learn more about
flash you get to learn
about they do wonder woman is done just
handled better
perfectly much better like when i get to
my segment i'll get it i just don't want
to jump in
i know you're time-sensitive yeah yeah
so that's that was it i've only seen an
hour and a half i'm excited to see the
rest because i said i've seen a lot of
new footage so i don't really
the rest of the movie i can't imagine
what's in there um so i'm excited to see
the rest no doubt solution
real quick shout out to mass i want i i
want to say
i remember math third count
i don't know it looked like
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
okay so we got cat daddy look with the
five dollar super chat
stakes on the grill iron lords and the
speakers what a sunday
you all ready yo cat daddy what's up
brother yes sir then we have flame five
dollar super chat hear ye
hear ye the acquisition of evo makes
sense for playstation fans
since they're stuck watching other
others play games
since there's nothing to play
wow wow wow we got more we got more
we got submitted we got smitty smith 20
super chat salute ilp
lognet lord addict show and of course
the last word salute
i just wanted to say thank you for your
time and your effort and i have
tremendous respect and mad love for
y'all
yo and shout out to the moderators in
chat thank you for saluting me man he's
with my dude
yeah that's been it that's all right and
of course we have the incredible hulk of
this
aka the access game the prophet of
xbox king of the statues who demands
nothing less than that premium
experience
it is the leader of the fraud alert
movement
oh beloved lord king how we doing sir
y'all ready for next sunday this sunday
is crazy
see what a symbol has going on in the
background
when he jumped in i swear i fanboyed out
geeked out really quickly
you know um i love anybody that sits
there and take time out and they display
and he has meticulously uh assembled
each cube
to to tell a story and i know he was
telling a story in his head and he want
that
visual to hit you and it did and i do
appreciate your time and your efforts
sir
the comic box the spider-man comic box
yes flips it's two-sided it's carnage on
the other side
really wow
half of the stuff inside these cubes is
placeholders the only ones that
is that aren't placeholders is the dr
doom cell
it's not a placeholder the kingpin cell
i'm waiting for my xm daredevil to come
in
he's going to slide on the side of him
because i feel
daredevil and kingpin are more akin than
spiderman and um
agreed so i have the hobgoblin in there
because he had a role in the hobgoblin
with spider-man hold on and that's my
favorite spider-man 2 real quick because
uh sweetie smith wanted to correct his
error
he said i didn't forget kos find out i
wanted to give you your own super chat
the book of acts
just really quickly he's time sensitive
um on uh dcx i
expound it on justice league schneider
cut
you guys know i don't like his views on
heroes i don't like his views on heroes
and humanity
as a whole he has a very dark outlook on
it and i understand
life uh life uh things that happen to
you in life changes your views on things
and i
truly get it and he wants them grounded
in a manner
that makes sense to this world but i
don't come from this world
how we live it now i come from the comic
book world and everything is sunshine
and rainbows
some bad stuff that go on now i can
never go back i watched the josh whedon
cut after i watched the story because
yeah i did eight hours of movies yeah
yeah whatever
and i'm going to go back and watch the
snyder cut because it's that damn good i
give it a 8.9
um i think he did his thing and it's
that good because he has a clear vision
from point a to point b
it's not a franken movie yeah josh
whedon for both of those individuals
that was a low point because neither one
of them got credit but both of them got
blamed
right you understand so and i think wb
gets
blamed because if josh whedon would had
his own justice league movie
it would have been a better movie and we
got zack snyder's complete
view of the justice league
be it this i thought the character
development like my
um my co-host here explained
was phenomenal we get that before
i saw the powers of the superheroes
which was the on display
wonder woman was done in a manner that
was great that one scene that you had
with her
was fleshed out and was done perfectly
so you can
see things better now his overuse of uh
slow motion people right complaining
about his oval use of slow motion
you got to do it for superman you have
to do it he let
wonder woman beat himself in that one
scene and you saw how blazingly fast she
was
yeah and it was just like wow i had to
rewind it again
because he gave me what i wanted from
wonder woman um
the flash uh he fixed the run my biggest
problem with the flash
was the run you know it's funny kai bus
who hates the run i heard them talking
about it
the reason why run is weird the one in
the beginning
the first one was a feminism right and
the it's not a typical of that character
to have that type of run
so now because he runs straight up right
so when he's
throwing his arms like this it
it it will put a flash fan off right
zach fixed it right and zach gave more
context to him
to show that he isn't as experienced as
the others
yeah absolutely right so now you can say
oh i get he's not just a joke
batman is batman he's the baddest
dude in the land right i mean superman
comes and does his thing but
batman is the dude because he singly can
take down every last one of them so
thank god he's actually really good and
he's not the butt of
every joke that josh whedon did i think
he hates batman
um and he he made batman the butt of
every joke but
superman comes up and everything is
great the movie is fantastic and it's
his vision and i'm happy that the
internet won
all you guys that that fought for this
all you guys that wanted this
all you guys that would not accept that
first movie your voices was hurt
this is the games i've been playing
rage two
it's yo uh uh cog you mute it
okay sorry rage
two i can't um
it's it's the most amazing thing i've
like
if you could pull me from destiny i'm
stuck playing it yes i have every
bethesda game yes i paid for these games
i know you're saying gamepad stops now
you know all these games already came
out listen my son didn't get a chance to
play these games
this stuff that was released is for
people that missed out on certain games
that
didn't have these games and it's for
people that are
new all right and if you do have these
games they have something for you it's
called boost mode
so all the the haters on the game pass
you know stop it but this rage
2 please put the field of vision up
oh my god the world is so huge so
colorful so bright so beautiful
we had boxing yesterday and i'm playing
destiny um getting my butt kicked in
trials i saw you playing trials last
night i wanted to jump in there
uh sinister can i finish my card can i
please get to the lighthouse
yeah we gotta get it was it was a rough
night it was a referendum you baxter
just want to make sure
yeah yeah i'm back okay quiet did you
introduce what was you playing anything
good this week besides pretty much just
been playing the outer world so yeah
all week i think because i started a new
character
yeah because i when i played the
original one like
it i liked it but i knew like you be
you know i've been saying it like over
and over again they they dropped that 60
frames
60 baby like different yeah and now
you know i'm uh yeah i'm already level
20 again
you know it's it's it's definitely been
uh and i'm completely going with like a
different build than i did last time
nice nice that's pretty much it right
falcon and winter soldier sorry
yeah and uh you know cider's cut like
the only thing that um
i can really a lot of she's throwing up
the time on us yeah
i'm not going to say anything like that
but like the only thing i could say is
like
i think one of the reasons that you see
this game this movie being a lot more
good reception it's just because like
i'm sure the original developer
the original director didn't have four
hours like that yeah
that that's a lot of time like when you
don't do stuff efficient
like marvel does and you want to jump
you want to jump five years six years
you don't want to show this movie to
explain this dude and this movie to
explain this dude
and you want one movie to explain all
the dudes like it's
for every hero that you introduce into a
random movie
that's like 30 minutes of a backstory
yeah
and they had like three of them that he
did obviously
and it's like i said like you know if
you introduce um
flash in a different movie you introduce
well who else
there was a couple of them but you have
what i'm saying like if they would have
had their own movies
cyborg yeah cyborg you could have took
those segments of that backstory out of
the
uh i out of the justice league and you
could have replaced it with you know
substance to the main story but they
couldn't do that
and i think that's the reason that you
know zach had more to work with because
he had
way more time like what the original one
was like not even two hours long
i think i think this is the only context
that we get a movie of this length like
that like so
i know i think it's gonna happen more
okay time
this is on limited time we are doing it
i'll give you more oh okay okay you show
up okay
i'll give you an introduction too much
fun wait a minute
i don't want to get just that means that
means that means
problems yeah exactly i'm trying to save
a lot of stuff just let me say this
right now
yeah this and and then we'll move on
like i think we'll see more
movies like this kind of length because
like they didn't have to worry about the
movies
like that that's one of the reasons
because the movies press them like we
we don't want this being four hours long
we're trying to show eight
showings in one day i get it i'll get it
i'll say jesse
i thought so i thought the ex not last
thing on justice
the justice league it was amazing
the one thing that on that point of the
timing and you're right
the theaters i think have a little more
control over like hey we can't we got to
show this in eight different showings
and all this time we can't do this time
because you put on hbo the idea behind
time for a movie is irrelevant because
now the viewer can sit there and go
i'll watch an hour and a half i'll watch
four hours straight
watch it again i'll watch 20 minutes now
you are not beholden to
time so now if they want to do it again
based on the success of it
yeah and hbo will go look we're making
gobs of money you got to do more you got
to do more
now a director has to say i don't need a
formula this could be i could do a 45
minute
epilogue right again you know just a bit
little bite size or i could make a six
hour mini series
yep but i think it could it could change
the game i don't see how they don't go
back to it and say
we need to they could have changed those
chapters to be individual episodes that
made it a mini series exactly
and i think that was a thing that was a
plan
yeah right you see it and when i saw a
falcon and winter soldier
and i love marvel coming out swinging
hard pause
i mean no they really i was afraid for
certain things
and we know disney's not going to show
blood but this thing went in
from the moment because wanda and the
and the vision one division
that was a little soft-handed and people
were put off by a couple episodes and
said i see it as an entirety and by the
time we got to the last
yeah the last episode i was like i want
more right
the falcon in the winter soldier from
the bell comes out
swinging like really fantastic stuff so
we're getting all the stuff that we want
for being imprisoned at home
right now yeah great stuff you can hear
a cock's voice out he's like stop it
we just i'm like all right
listen we could talk about ufc for 40
minutes
i was respecting our guests
i know so i relaxed
since everybody's still at home movie
theaters are kind of not a thing yet we
need to
revisit roundtable table yeah with the
lawyers we need to do
that yeah we need to remember because
now we can all do it because now we can
all do
it no you're right absolutely arnold
will come back and we spend a lot for
the intro we need to use it
so can we get the uh the super chats
here oh yes we have a few
uh we got 108 dragons with the five
dollar super attack good afternoon lord
so zack snyder cut gave
each character the proper time they
deserved whereas the previous movie was
just rushed awesome movie
now facts that's true then we got
middle-aged game guy with the five
dollars
i like that yeah last week's podcast was
so long
i just finished it
sunday is the lord's day you guys are
all incredible thank you sir
thank you guys podcast then we have a
fandom kraken two dollar super chat
hashtag restore the snyder verse yeah i
i i want to see that are we sure that's
not luca and disguise
yeah it could be good then we have rob c
with the 20
super chat showing some love thanks
lords for making my sunday
absolutely sir appreciate it then we got
ksanti five dollar super chat salute to
the lords
i'm a marvel zombie but i gotta say i
love the snyder cut
the jaw justice league only got all of
this
he had to shave it was spelling
only cut cut all the poc watch back to
uh
to back it's blatant if you do watch
them back to bank it is sort of night
and day
um then we have 108 dragons once again
five dollars can't wait for that 4k
release the original movie is
in the bushes when zack was watching the
original movie he was probably like
taking it he had like his little
i'm sure he seen it at one point i'm
talking about from
releasing toenails he's never watched it
i don't know i truly believe i don't
believe that one bit that didn't
happen i don't believe that first he had
his own real
to watch his own stuff and second if you
unceremoniously booted from a project
disrespected in a manner that he was
disrespected after they begged him to do
something
would you if you're an architect would
you go past that building that they
asked you to build oh
he does what some of these gamers do
when they when they play something that
they be
bashing he he appeared offline watch
he probably was probably lurking my man
doesn't have integrity here
no he has pride integrity and a huge ego
and he said hell to the know
just to stick it to bobby down the lady
torrence
[Music]
wait a minute did addicts shave who is
this imposter
shave oh it's attic squirrel today put
the attic world up y'all
i said the same thing i feel a little
uncomfortable man there's too many
people
in this chat commenting on my beard man
dude this is a revelation
uncomfortable i have to do this
shout out to the aisle feed crew and
guest guest who
got a two terabyte nvme ssd for 320
dollars
hello oh with the stimmy because i need
more space for all these not
games xbox ads oh damn
there we have general mack with the ten
dollars of attack good morning good
afternoon for the east coast catch shout
out to the iron lords
another great show another great guest
was able to grab that little man from my
little man
game past
then we have john g john g john c uh
five dollar super chat
uh send five dollars sent five dollars
to save falcon and winner soda was all
content and no substance
oh that's a shot
funny honestly your opinion is alive
you know what it is and and just just
time we gotta go
go wait
right now
hit me up and let me know what you think
about it and make sure you put the
field of view view up you know no doubt
yeah i didn't know they didn't really go
into detail but the outer worlds has a
field of view now
like they just talked about the 60
frames but it's got a field of view now
because people don't understand that you
can go change that now
we have a button
we have squirrelly there two dollars
chad heads up iop we're moving to the
east coast
oh pull up pull up once things get right
yeah we got it we gotta hang out with
squirrely that's what's up
no doubt leaving canada that's crazy
yellow life
and we got gerald mack five dollars
super chat trying to hit that live
teespring need help
uh what's going on you can't hit the
lick the licks up brother
yeah oh i can put the leg back in there
if you can't hit it but uh yeah continue
so
then we got stitch with the five dollar
super chat king can you tell your man
cog to stop
capping for these watered-down swiss
ports please what did you count for us
that is an old beef yeah he just he
don't like me talking anything about
sweden
yeah they don't even say he he a fake uh
tom brady fan but not a buck fan i don't
know what's going on stitches in another
world
he just gets this imaginary beef with me
continue all right we're caught up
all right let's go all right let's get
to this thank you
let's go let's go and of course you got
the host cognito just you know
oh
right oh yeah look man last word last
night tj teddy um
ty got travis hilarious show watch that
it was funny um finished got some games
finished
my second playthrough of gears tactics
uh vault done
outstanding please if you haven't played
it play it's it's phenomenal um
and then also until the end want to
thank steven lord stephen and
uh sarah danton finally finished that
game i love you we had you on the show
um it's in game pass right now so i
gotta shout out game pass but um you
lied
that that thing is a 2d dark souls game
that thing is not
i thought it was another world i mean it
is atmospheric
but that thing is hard and yeah we're
going to talk about that but i i got my
100
1000 of the achievements so i'm very
proud of that
um yakuza like a dragon getting back
into that game is absolutely hilarious
empire of sin from the turn-based guys
funny 1920s gangster
prohibition al capone all the fly check
that out if you'd like um turn base it's
really good it's a game pass as well
and uh i got to set up my quest to i got
to get that done this weekend because i
got to the vr i've been me and king got
to talk
so that's what i got so now that the
lords have finally finished their marvel
versus
dc discussion to talk more about it
and uh yeah we could now focus how do
you feel about the flag
[Laughter]
never ever changed salute the book of
acts uh 45 minutes is really uh
cutting us short that's kind of that's
true man
like a two-hour interest salute man sean
capri good to see you brother atl thank
you
much appreciate it so now we focus on
that good stuff let's focus back
on lord assemble his video game system
history
his journey as a content creator and of
course what led him to creating the
amazing
assemble youtube channel so lord
assemble let's start from the very
beginning what were some of the first
video game systems you had
and what got you into gaming oh uh
nes um classics mario zelda
then moving on to snes i never genesis
i know it was a nintendo house so it was
mario
it was star fox uh it was
then all the wrestling games for yes
before oh what wrestling game
specifically no mercy
no mercy wrestlemania 2000 oh the goats
oh you need the
goats 18 yes i mean
the goat is revenge attitude on the snes
yes were you there earlier
are you just a wwe guy and you wasn't
there during the the nwo phase of those
games
lbcw nwo revenge and world tour come on
n64 let's go
all day smashing chairs outside no dq
all day long okay yes
i'm talking about yes okay don't worry i
was there with you continue
that's the gamecube that's the gamecube
one nothing
that you had the black mountain yeah i
didn't like the resume it was like a big
oh then i mean then it just got into the
playstation
and stayed on the sony side i didn't get
into
xbox on first gen and i was late to 360
because i was just with
sony's side the whole way through and
then i finally went back into the 360
era towards the end and picked one up
and then the xbox one the big
giant vcr and i jumped in that day one
and then it's funny because now i have
the playstation 5 and i'm lucky enough
to be
able to pick those up yes um the ps5 and
the siri
series x and i am
right now i'm so much more into my xbox
and it's not just because of you know
bethesda and all and game pass i just
i enjoy the experience i like my
controller better i just
i don't know it's just kind of my
ecosystem like any of my third-party
titles i'm playing there
and ps5 is like my you know aaa
sony only also it's catching dust
oh [ __ ] i'm winning i played spider-man
a couple times
me too i played white spider-man and
then i got my mom's brother a couple
times your question question but it has
been turned off for about a month
question the question all right so uh
could you breeze past he breathes
through yeah
i had to no no it's getting shorter time
no no this is your time now this is this
is yours no this don't matter this is
you want to rock this time this is your
time but a question all right so i know
these consoles these current generation
consoles we have now
you have uh purchased them at launch yes
now what is your launch
type history with your previous consoles
because the you know like earlier
playstation people think this is a new
thing
like like oh we can't find consoles and
oh it was it was hard to get
did you were you a part of any launch
parties
or uh you know waiting on lines you know
because we didn't get tickets back in
the days we just had to risk our lives
yup thanks be out there get outside yeah
yeah last gen for ps4 i waited outside i
went to
it was the night of launch so i drove
around to eb games looked at the lineup
went nope
went to walmart where i'm like okay
there's like a secluded walmart like
there's nobody out there
the locals are there that's it yeah i go
out and i i drove in and i got to like
the front door and i was like she's like
we're looking for a playstation i was
like yeah she goes nah we're at capacity
90 people
done forget it you can't come in the
door i said okay
i go home i go to bed i tell my wife i
need to go get coffee
at 6 00 a.m and then i drive to
at the time and and outside outside of
toronto where i am
we had target target was in canada for
like a year and a half
so we had target so i went to the target
i was like was the only target in the
area i'm like
let's see i stood in line and i crapped
you not there was
me and some other like 12 year old oh
that was a doubt
that was it oh wow and i asked the guy i
was like hey do you so do you have any
he's like yeah we've got like 50. what
200
guys oh you had the goldman spy yeah
nobody knew there's like 12 people
waiting so that was
yeah they don't like to argue together
what's going on in the six man
[Laughter]
otherwise it was all just i just waited
and i don't remember yeah eb
uh for the ps3 i went to eb games maybe
a couple of weeks after
uh it launched for the ps3 and i was
able to walk in and get the console
so yeah on those sides anyways i didn't
have much of a shortage but it wasn't
day one
gotta get it oh okay i'm into the most
recent yeah about tremendous history
with that you know just real quick um
were you a handheld guide off trying to
bring the handhelds back is it was it
any handhelds any game boys i mean game
boy okay
okay okay tetris i played tetris and
mega man
oh yeah addict left soon as you said
[Laughter]
yeah game boy was probably the only
exposure there until
now with the switch and i think i had a
game gear at some point oh i remember
getting one
guru i just had one last question i'm
sorry
no no i was gonna say last question back
because you said it was a nintendo
household
right yes so my question was was there
any friends that had genesis or what
like what
yeah where like like what was going on
that i mean everybody has that you're
like you got one and you go to the other
buddies house to go play the other one
so
all my buddy it was that's how it was it
was we had mario kart and mario world
and everything and then
i go over my buddy's place to do all the
genesis games and i'd be sitting there
playing mortal kombat
for the most part and then
then same thing when i got into sony
into playstation
all my buddies had xbox so my exposure
to halo 1
going local lan party where they're
hooking up dual
uh xbox og xboxes that was my exposure
to halo
until i got my 360 and i was like then i
went back and played a bit more
but i remember going to blockbuster when
i was a kid i remember going to
blockbuster and i rent you could rent
the consoles
out little guys yeah you could rent your
consoles for two days
and a big deposits and it was terrifying
you're walking out with this rented box
yeah
i rented the original xbox and played
halo
and what's the racing game that project
project gotham racing
yes so i played those all weekend long
and then returned it
nice nice absolutely that's beautiful
back to the days where you can rent
those systems man
yes it was i got a reference for that
later
real quick i want to shout out the
anonymous one i'll say the super chat i
know we missed a couple but
general macdanke he got that snapback i
saw you so the anonymous had purchased
was you
yes those were checked for um we got
lord mordecai with the five pound super
chat
time come on guys cog needs to finish
these thank you sir
thank you sir just trying to host that's
all i was trying to do
then we got flame five dollars we
thought i'm doing this now
hear ye hear ye play octopath traveler
on game pass when it hits
xbox to send square a message and
outriders two
it's okay factual faction we're gonna
play octopus traveler
we're any messages if they're in bed
with somebody they're in bed
let it go just play the game let's play
it again
uh then we had gerald mack five thousand
check yeah that anonymous purchase was
me shout out to the iron lord
and hold
lord fozzie kadrian hardy welcome to
lord gold put them crushed in the chat
thank you no doubt no doubt so
tremendous gaming history
and all that good stuff from assemble so
um i want to get into your personal
journey as like a content creator and
everything dirty so like
what made you kind of start a youtube
channel just in general
how did that whole process come up um
i've said this on another podcast too so
i
it's always it's been something that
i've always wanted to do and trying to
narrow down what i really wanted to
talk about and focus on i enjoy the
i i enjoy the kind of the nerdy process
of editing
and going through it and just yeah kind
of just talking video games and really
just in
marvel and dc and everything that we're
talking about and
it honestly it took me five years to
get it together to say just turn on a
camera turn on your smartphone
and go i started with king you like i
started off with like doing the reviews
of
figures and statues and that was a lot
of just getting my feet wet with um
using my phone edit basic stuff on my
old pc
and just try it and just see how i liked
going through it and i started to get
a little bit more traction just wanting
to do it and
i've now had the channel for like one
year
um and the growth is and the reception's
been really like really really nice
so i'm really excited about it i just
started trying to get my focus down
further and further but i kind of said
to myself honestly i was like you know
enough's enough um you want to do it
try it and and see what's up and i
i really love it so i'm really enjoying
what we're doing and what i'm doing and
i kind of just said i'm going to go all
in so i saved and saved you guys are
like hey your camera's nice i'm like
yeah
i work my tail off and i'm like okay i'm
going to get a pc
that is not like a 2012 mac
and trying to run program software on it
doesn't work that was me at the
beginning yeah
okay i'm going to get a decent pc and
the camera and i'm like i want to make
this
my own so yeah i started growing
everything and now it's
i'm really enjoying the process of like
just talking games every day
talking marvel dc and uh i launched my
patreon probably two days ago
oh wow i'm excited for that too so yeah
just enjoying the process and it's just
been a lot of fun and the community's
been amazing
well yeah like i'm eyeballing
all right easter
because i'm looking at his display and i
see he got some sideshow pieces and
stuff like that
and i understand
like what you said you grab your phone
let me go for it
let me just talk about my passion let me
talk from my heart let me explain to
them
this is what i'm getting this is the
collector that i got and you were doing
your reviews and stuff like that
and then to expound on it and we knew
sovereign knew automatically we have
visual
uh you know your camera was hitting
right and then you know you give us the
background about the camera
and i know enough from one away dragons
to know
so it's a gateway the camera is a
gateway but that lens
is we learned about that lens in the
pre-show
right so and you did all of this stuff
and it's it's really paying off like you
said you lost
launch your patreon and i advise
everybody to go subscribe to this
channel and i'm going to go
dive deeper into uh his channel
right now because uh um i'm truly into
that and i think that stuff should be
celebrated because
like you said it it holds on to like a
child in you that
child feeling that i know how you feel
trust me
i know how you feel when you get a new
anything in
and you're sitting there you're opening
i'm too out of control right now i love
you
i swear i love each and if i was in your
house i'd probably sit on the floor
you just sit right there
don't touch it just look you know hands
and hands on your waist
that's right um but thank you so i do
appreciate your passion and it's come
through
on camera yeah that [ __ ] really came
through
the u.s it's here oh yeah absolutely
just don't we just don't tell the wife
about some of the purchases
this this right here yeah i didn't say
anything
i have i got at christmas time
a buddy of mine went back home he went
back to japan
and i was like so could you look for
some figures for me
and he's like yeah there's like shops
everywhere so he got me
um captain america there
iron man and the infinity gauntlet
it's over there and they're just on the
shelves
talk to her about that they they just
my goodness that's right it's in the
front in the case
that's the problem the funny thing is
i can't get away with that in my house
my wife notices
everything every she's like hold up
[Laughter]
i'm in the basement so everything just
comes into the door
[Music]
savages damage beautiful stuff i love it
so let me ask you a question
um as far as the content on your channel
is it something that you
haven't done yet that you're uh thinking
about exploring and having trepidation
with it
or have you just flushed out where you
want to be and you're comfortable
in your zone now starting to find my
zone and starting to find my groove
where i'm like
i i've grown up with for tv anyways like
daily show letterman all of that
and i've i've wanted to be able to
encapsulate kind of like i enjoy the
daily
and i enjoy doing like almost the games
daily coverage
and and just talk about some of the
games that i like and
what's kind of the big main topics in
ten polls and then just try to put my
spin on it throw a little humor in there
and
you know if people like it they like it
so it's i'm starting to really find my
groove where i'm like oh i like
i like this approach and for me it's a
lot of get in get out
my episodes and stuff early on it's
trial and error like we all do so it's
going from a 20-minute episode on x-men
movie reviews i'm like wait a minute
this isn't relevant at all
so it's just fun to do but you know no
one's going to watch that so now i'm
finding them
getting my stride and i'm trying to make
sure that because it's it's just me
that i can make them short and sweet so
if i can make things
concise i don't want to stare at my face
for 25 minutes
and because it's not a podcast so to do
that much content for that long you're
going to lose i'm going to lose viewers
interest
real quick and so i try to make sure
that my shows are like
six minutes eight minutes ten max and
it's trying to just get you and get you
out
maximize graphics music and try to take
it up a notch because
i watch a ton of content out there too
and
some of it's my absolute favorites and
it's it's well done i just enjoy the
conversation
but it's i want to try to put more
production into it
yeah even for the daily stuff and like
okay if i got six minutes i'm trying to
make it as punchy in six minutes as i
can
and now you know what and to be honest
with you i
really feel that because i say it's a
lot of statue review guys out there
right and then the first thing i do is
look at the time stamp and the time
thing
is like 35 minutes yeah and i'm i'm
speeding through stuff
so i just try to get in on my statues
give you
a quick synopsis and you know show the
statue
and then i'm out of there and if you
want to go to the website to see the
dimensions and the weight and stuff like
that
and i think your thought process in
doing how you're doing it
is perfect because that way you're going
to maximize
eyes on your channel because i will give
you uh
40 minutes of you know give me 10
episodes
you know whatever and and i think that
you will retain
more viewership that way because
i'm episode after episode and seeing
things and seeing how you twist things
and do
things differently so i'm very
interested and i can't wait to
after the podcast to just sit there and
you know
uh view all your stuff because honestly
i definitely am
yo stew jersey is stupid he said
watching king of the symbol talk reminds
me of ant-man talking to goliath
65 whoa
jersey stupid
yo shout out to get gerald back i see
you man yeah cop the uh
then what you call it the uh the shirt
you know what i'm saying whatever
whatever
uh salute lawrence get super check i
think it's about to step away for a
quick second and then we'll get them
back in
if i didn't know we're good okay i'm
here now oh okay
the kids was like daddy what's going on
why are you we're going outside i'm like
again i gotta shout out our late brother
lord dizzy i'm so
thankful that he he's the one again that
recommended you
and we do share what i realized about
why is that
you do share so many passions that the
lord [ __ ] you know saying you got the
statues you got the comic books you know
what i'm saying
so the thing like what inspired you to
kind of like merge
all these worlds together because we
actually got in trouble like oh you guys
talking sports and
all you guys yeah why are you talking
about the damn one where's the games
get to the topic but like it's fun
because i love that you kind of do the
same thing you got gaming
wrestling movies collecting like what
inspired you to
merge those worlds i think it's just
because there's so much overlap which is
what i think we all deal with like and
you just
i don't know they just all blend because
if you are just talking whether you are
on a podcast and you're four five six
people
it goes into different directions like
that because we
typically all have the same interest if
you're looking at marvel and avengers
and all this you'd probably dabble in
games too
and then you might dabble in sports and
vice versa and for me it's
it's sitting there going well i like
games i don't have time to play every
single major game that comes out
so i want to talk to the community about
just some of the stuff we're playing and
i know other people are too
and it's going to lend into and lead
into you know avengers and
like when the ninja turtles game got
announced for the shredders oh yeah i
lost my mind over there
bro that spoke to us yeah so it's
there's always gonna i can't just sit
there and go i'm just gonna do marvel's
avengers game coverage
um because i'll get bored and yeah i
just think that it's
it is a melting pot as much as we all
want to say get to the games and
it's a game podcast talk about this like
well we do
it's just there it's a little bit for
everybody right
completely everyone wants to cover
justice league like i did i've got
a spoiler-free review that's out and
it's just because i'm like but i enjoy
it and i know
somebody else does and king's like
justice league
wonder woman's great scenes and i'm like
well so do i and if for me
it's honestly i'm like well i say it
often enough like to people on twitter
and stuff i'm like hey
10 of you watched the justice league
spoiler free review i'm like that's
amazing that's what's up
you guys took time and i'm like you gave
up 20 minutes or whatever
to chill and talk to me and hang out and
you know go through the review i'm like
that's awesome because i like to look at
it i try to look at it like
man those are bodies and those are
people and if you're in a room if you
were in a theater
if you were standing on stage and you
were doing it yeah you would be blown
away that you were sitting there going
400 people are sitting there and
watching
a podcast yep so when i sit there go i
got a justice league review with
whatever 40 people that i've seen i'm
like
geez thank you no absolutely completely
completely agree i mean
king and you know solve we know you know
saying like just starting out and
you know you're appreciative you're
appreciative that people you know come
in to actually
you know hear your take and your your
perspective on those things and again
shout out to you for just like
merging those worlds because again we
appreciate it you don't say like again
you made a great point about overlap
right yeah a lot of this is melody even
when we talk ufc boxing this you'll see
boxing games it comes out you know what
i'm saying well boxing has been a while
but there was fight night remember
you know what i said but um yeah like it
it it's cool to see and um
also two questions in relation to that
let's like i notice you do
some 90s cartoons a little x-men giant
you know what i'm saying
and you look at that
wrestling i sort of wrestle i think
somebody appreciate that
like what you got you still talking
about events and things of that nature
you're still going on with that you got
to slow down with that i slowed that
down a little bit and it's only
a lot of it's just due to time yeah
because it's funny because when i
started
uh other channel and then i subsequently
deleted
the whole thing and started from scratch
the whole thing was all just wrestling
podcast and youtube show and i just
dumped it because one it was too
time-consuming of daily and i'm like if
i wanted to really invest in it then i'm
gonna go all the way
and i couldn't give that i'm like okay i
like being more of a fan
and even now i enjoy talking about the
news and rumors and
the pay-per-views and everything and i
still want to do that and i might just
scale back and go all right i'm going to
go with just more of the pay-per-views
okay and maybe just do recaps on that
and i might just go in that direction
but for now and i'm like and it's also
looking at going well what's
what's making me happy on the channel
what am i enjoying doing the most
and what are people gravitating towards
the most so it's understanding
the ugly algorithm and going people like
avengers and they like talking about the
latest in xbox and game pass i'm like
well cool so do i so
let's just focus on that for a while i
wanted um a person
to do uh write-ups on uh log net
about um wrestling because
i feel disconnected from it i used to be
so so connected yeah right
you know when uh when the undertaker
turned from mean mark
into the undertaking exactly you know
stuff like that and
you know uh ted dibiase and all these
guys and everyone's got a place
uh jake the snake and i was into really
really into the stuff in that uh uh
fostered my gaming as well because like
you you talked about these wrestling
games
we were playing the characters that we
saw on tv and we loved these guys and we
were doing things that
we were hoping that we can do you know
and i got a chance to go to a couple of
pay-per-views
so that stuff is fantastic i want
somebody to help connect me back to this
generation
you know so because i go to login and i
read uh reviews once when you know
people put stuff out yeah and i was
talking to dizzy about that before you
know god bless you so
um and i'm like you know i really want a
wrestling dude
because i'm so disconnected and i told
her cog is like yeah so you're talking
about that and
please do it like by the way lord gave
me that that has a position open for you
if you ever
it's what king is saying that's what
you're really saying you know like i'm
poaching like a culture
shooting yes sir
fine i'll do it fine i'll
um if you had to pick one baby there's a
fire
it's a fire all right like any baby in
the world or just like
my actual children the statues oh that's
your baby
which is the one you're grabbing which
one's all the real ones the resin babies
yeah which one are you running now so
you got some statue statues
which one are you running out of here
with ooh
tough there's two but the one is going
to be spider-man cause my wife got me
that one
so okay that's my infinity war
spider-man
love him or it's going to be the g1
optimus prime oh
my man roll out listen okay so in my
head i had a bet
right in my head i had a bet with your
g1 optimus prime
yes i actually think i would go with
optimus because that is
it looks just too pretty it looks just
like the show that's the card
right there yeah porsche power um shout
out to um
ainsley aisley has the same one
and um i'm like yo it looks so amazing
and
yeah cause my my eyes is really fixated
right
because also you can change out the hand
or the arm or
his blade yeah oh you could do it you do
the cartoon yeah yeah
yeah oh that's what's up that's
something from you got that from
sideshow right
yep yep that was the yeah i probably
would go with that honestly because that
was the first one that i bought
that i really was like i love the
staring at sideshow on the website just
for
weeks and weeks and i'm like all right
i'm gonna do this and then matt forgot
that i'm like oh it's in the u.s and
there's there's duty and there's they're
shipping fees and i was like oh this is
not
that cheap so but i i absolutely love
that thing
i geeked out so hard i'm like that is
the first statue that i've owned that
it meant a lot and yeah i was like yeah
i'll go with houston's friends
absolutely
did you change your profile name did we
talk about justice league here
you're a savage and that's what i will
be
until something else happens
it really it really don't i didn't get a
chance to talk to you about it
it doesn't matter my name's we talk
about justice league
[Laughter]
anyway oh so look man correct me if i'm
wrong
um in real life you actually have some
experience as far as from our um
corporate standpoint of uh kind of
assisting people with what i think is
really cool with mental health
you know depression and anxiety issues
so yeah so i've done
corporate training for over 10 years
and uh as a trainer facilitator it's the
guest of the on stage piece right so
i've done
big stuff and several hundred people in
the theater
doing a couple hours of stuff and daily
so
um but a lot of the stuff that i did do
was yeah there's the the corporate
sales side and corporate training side
but i also uh
got into with some other companies on
the mental health side and dealing with
anxiety and depression and
strategies and ways to cope with it and
no i am not
legally certified to give that advice
but it was a lot of just
here's the daily stuff you're here
trying to relate and connect the
thoughts of like everything that we all
deal with from getting up in the morning
and having barriers or feeling down and
or or really just struggles with work
and colleagues and
how do i manage the stress anxiety
frustration
all of those things whether it's from a
text an email whatever
and even getting you know angry and
frustrated when you're driving home and
your phone is still dinging at you
more stuff you want more of your time
all of that so that's what i was
coaching that's what i was training on
uh for quite a while and and just trying
to give people a little bit of help with
your strategies here's ways to maybe
make that hour
a little bit better and uh yeah just to
set you up for a little more success
that's what i was doing for a better
half of 10 years which parlayed as i
talked to my wife before
i'm like oh it kind of has helped i
think with
me on the show because i have no
issues like for a lot of people starting
off it's like okay i gotta get in front
of a camera yeah
yeah there's anxiety i'm not used to it
king forced us out there okay
is
people connect with you on a different
level instead of because i was so sick
and tired of going to people's channels
seeing a stupid little avatar beeping
like you know like he's talking now his
avatar is
[Music]
yo yo
a level of emotion that you can get this
this is how we are as humans we want to
see what's going on so we know if
somebody's being shiesty or being real
we want to
read this fact if we cannot read this
then i don't need to be here so
if your avatar is your main thing
goodbye i don't care about your content
i don't care about anything about it but
seeing
your background seeing you emotes you
know that brings
a life to it that makes me stay yeah
you make no such thing it's listen shout
out to king because
he like i said we were kicking and
scratching it was
it was a process for us he doesn't need
to be
it's not for everybody right like it is
a process and it's it's hard so at least
for me i was like okay i have no
problems of hit play go
and just spit it off and spout it out
and even for
content people have asked me before
they're like so how much is
your scripting and like what's the
process for it for like shooting an
episode i'm like
bullet points on my phone like i
literally would be like what's the
heading of the article and i'm like okay
go
yep that's right it's at most it's topic
one two and three it could be like it's
the bethesda deal
look at the games got them up like go
and let's just talk for
six minutes so realness at the end of
the day
the reason i didn't have to show my face
faces because my avatar's a sexy beast
anyway
my avatar you know what's funny when
when they were first doing these avatars
things
i was so against me being the what i am
i was like man i was like that's the one
like
that's the one that like eats a lot and
stuff like i don't have like diseases
on my avatar and stuff he's like you
picked this are you talking about the
pestilence
i'm just saying this like because i give
you a fraud alert because
i only say it because when you got a
haircut right now
oh you bro you could have bro
you made people figure if that added who
stole that
you know because they care about your
beard
you know they wouldn't care about your
beard if it's just your average
avatar because they don't care they
don't care your avatar
is a cartoon you know what my if if my
avatar was there it wouldn't matter
it's like like i want you to visualize
me as that advocate no that's disgusting
anyway i wanted to shout out uh
something with that because i think
that's really cool you know what you're
doing mental health and the inclusion in
your channel because i do think
that is a big thing with us as gamers
and there's a lot of gamers that you
know
i think we go through it and they they
utilize podcasts
as that outlet to connect right you know
we talked about cameras we're talking
about all this stuff but
a lot of it again we're grateful for
everyone here yeah yeah
yeah that expensive camera man we might
have to really sit back and
and evaluate oh yeah we're going to talk
about that camera looks like
that chris crispy he created clean up he
clean so yeah but i wanted to salute you
because again you don't see that you
know for sure though
two quick five questions um i want to
say as far as um
the simple one the history behind the
name it's gotta be
marvel adventures the sample like it it
has to be oh that's all it is
okay that's all it is it was me sitting
at starbucks with my computer one
morning being like okay
i'm gonna do this what do i want to call
it and what could i use something that i
like
and that could be kind of i could just
kind of use
universally for for anything so yeah i
landed on assemble
i don't think it was going to be called
much else i was like i can't use my name
no i don't care
so i wanted to use something i'm like oh
people know where that's from and i'm
like okay cool then it just kind of it
just kind of works
love it love it love it love it and it's
going to be a bonus round because we do
our normal top fives but we got to do a
bonus round special one
[ __ ] assemble so i need
the top five comic book movies either
mcu or dc
of all time your top five let's go
batman 1989 schneider cut is now going
to be on my list i think because i am i
am
loving this thing infinity war
hold a backup back but that's the key
which one is that keaton
okay
[Music]
uh let's say infinity war
spider-man homecoming homecoming wow
one more one more original iron man
because they kicked it off
okay so you're paying homage okay okay
okay okay that one yeah
i think of the other series i'm like
yeah cat movies are no take that out
take ironman out and i'll go
uh with your soldier soldier you are
welcome back
every single season
i didn't say that i was gonna ask you
listen i knew what he was doing
i didn't
you know i wasn't going to say anything
and i really hoped that you would have
ended with iron man
and let him go into the bushes um
winter soldier is probably yeah
we just winter soldier is probably
their most concise movie tyson
you know from beginning to end and fight
scenes forget about iron man
don't worry about it yeah but definitely
yeah i'm a junkie for all that stuff
that you're talking about i geek out on
everything that you say and i know uh
how you feel about the stuff so
if somebody was to ask me that age of
ultron is the first one regardless
it's a better movie than people give it
credit for
[Laughter]
it's something we do we used to do r and
r and all that stuff
when the world was not covered ready but
uh yeah salute tremendous tremendous
now games yes top five video games or
franchises
of all time i know two of them you
better pick two that i think i know of
yours
uh all time i would say wwf no mercy
uh mlb the show as a franchise oh yeah
xbox bro bro solve is your best friend
forever now um
[Music]
i'm gonna record my whole purchase
probably call of duty as a franchise
because it's just that
junk junk food game that i'm like i only
i will go sit down and i will do
10 rounds of team deathmatch and i'm
just happy i'm content i feel you
um my first call of duty ever all on all
what you're gonna talk about that's
what's up
yo an old call of duty too original
original we talk about like
beta yeah i was playing on my pc
oh um well spider-man ps4 now ps5
oh i have platinum that and beat it and
gone back
and gone back so spider-man um like one
more
thing try to go something old on like
snes
i mean mario and all of that is easy but
i'm trying to think more of just in the
franchises we love um i'm looking at my
shelves
x-men but you know what um x-men
legends is another one it's not an
absolute top five like of all time
but i absolutely love that and as i look
at the comic box of
i think of maximum carnage okay okay
like that that is a memory of rent never
buying but renting
all the time every weekend going in and
i would buy
that crappy beat em up did you ever did
you ever play hulk ultimate destruction
yeah
i did that's a good game okay oh yeah
i love that game wow yeah so just some
of them yeah yeah
girl trumpet is tough i think you touch
every single lord here with a specific
choice
in some way yeah man definitely feeling
it at all
last one it would be the favorite uh
console of all time
past or present and why
my probably my snes or the amount of
games
that i played in that that was like the
core of my childhood or it would end up
being n64 for the same reasons
because i grew up right around that time
to really
really enjoy it and every time i think
of consoles i usually go back to that
as how many hours sitting there playing
mario kart and zelda
and mario world um especially
so i would probably say yeah it's going
to be the snes and if i get into my 64
yeah then i'm sitting there because i'm
like okay i've got no mercy
in 2000 and mario and mario kart
and star fox i'm just yeah so those
would be my two
i like the 64 too because i had that
expansion bay
for the
i remember when that expansion pack came
out because my dad got me withdrawals
mask and that was one of the first games
that used it yeah
and i remember like thinking if my mom
would have bought this i never would
have got that expansion but
she never would have known that would
have just been left at the store
i would just put it in there thinking my
n64 broke and i've been like
she broke it she gave me a bad copy of
that but it it didn't work without it
right
or i wasn't trying because i had it like
you know what i you know what i like
about the internet like like like a
little knife to like pry it out a little
bit or something
like that no i did not take it but you
liked about 64k
but i what i liked about the nintendo 64
was it was a lot of firsts yes and
nintendo is always blessed with
everything that they do and
and they try to introduce different
things to our consciousness as gamers
and that analog stick the the first
moment
when you walk mario up and you diesel
it was it was just it felt fantastic
fast you know can we at least admit that
that n64 controller wasn't it though
did you hold it down now too yeah it was
a batarang it was a batarang but it was
better but it
was different the precision right
like we didn't have that level when you
you made mario move in like a 360 degree
motion and you're like yeah no i'm
not saying the control but it was a
different level of control
and then you know the rumble pack yes or
fox like
you hitting something yeah it was it was
very introduced too
it's not like now where it's like all
kind of casual creeping up on you now
just bang
it was it was very it was what'd you do
i hit the start button
i'll go with you history man
bro we can talk about that next time you
got to come back when you got more time
absolutely give me one second two guys
do your thing give me one moment i'll be
right back yeah no doubt no doubt
but yeah man let's get the super chats
while we're waiting on uh someone to
come back uh we got two more super chats
we have one one away dragons with the
five dollar super chat
we as collectors and gamers and tech
heads we are faced with rough choices
wife or my hobbies um
coffee hobbies for the win open the
floodgates i
went away they made no tough choices
listen
i salute you for saying this in a dark
room where your wife
my wife is to my left right now she's
giving me a side eye like you're talking
about wives
it is no choice i lost many along this
road
get down to lay down okay it ain't no
choice
this is my choice there is literally
absolutely no choice is it yeah
if you ain't with me you're against me
goodbye
it's me or the video games of the
statues
we'll be playing video games on saturday
and my phone start the blazing and i'm
like yo don't call me again
do not call me again i'm gonna break
this phone don't call me again
and and literally the phone will ring
again and i smash the phone on the floor
and i said let's keep going guys and you
know fedex will be bringing me a new
phone the next day because uh she felt
that she had the [ __ ]
out for me to make sure that she got out
of contact with me but
at no point in time it was i giving up
my saturdays for my
you know for other than my team
saturdays
for some reason that there was naked
women serving hot dogs
i mean listen back then back then
my ex-wife at the time like she was like
y'all got to do what
we're going to watch movies watch sports
and play video games
for how long for like eight hours
okay no way
no no way grown men yo what is with this
misconception what's up
sam's got a wife i always thought he was
single player like sovereign yo
solve correct the misconception listen
the simple player part of the rhyme
has to do with the fact that i like to
play games by myself
yes on that there's no single player
nothing the player part the player part
of sovereignty that's always
done you realize you realize just
because you acknowledged that and you
gave it
yeah they
between it and make it sound like you're
saying something completely different
oh my god don't get no place
that handsome face can't be alone for
long
he definitely was that particular player
for a minute yeah i don't even know
but that was my choice yeah that's my
choice back in the day
let's let's move on let's move on let's
see like they don't want to talk about
them
super chat songs
speaking about people in the game before
saying five dollars super chat what
lord addict shaved his beard somebody
moved on
the chase trust me i had to chase my
wife for quite some time more like two
years you got this
are there amorous reasons for this [ __ ]
is there something going on
i i'm not calm
we got 500 people hit that like yo we
having fun
and uh share it out man uh let's get
more people just to go to symbols
channel and watch your stuff because
i'll be watching this stuff
daniella says songs exposed slow-mo it's
about to be a different
conversation after the podcast
i'm over here listen the levels of sweat
on me right now
look at his face it's ready he got ready
but look man we
we gotta respect lord and symbol he has
he has endured
extra he went into overtime with us
thank you keep going i kick your kids
outside they got their friends over i
kicked them outside i'm like there's a
trampoline there's
oh you go so you're wearing it out oh so
you're good i'll go out
oh so you get the rock okay oh my man
let's go
let's get it get to these diamonds
wouldn't you don't want to make that
joke like go play in traffic
like you're in the backyard trampoline
don't kill each other
and then you realize that's the
neighbor's backyard
you pay for a reason
attic the bit looks great more stylish
dude it does got a dip to it i've done
it
there we go
did you use that shave butter
you can't you can't call them grizzly
adams
[Music]
yeah right anyway moving a little
bit into these topics last week's poll
logic gaming.net poll is up the results
are in the people have spoken to the
question
regarding phil spencer clarifying but
does the games exclusive to platforms
where xbox game pass
exists which games do you feel are
multi-plat
contractual obligations or exceptions to
the rule
the choices and the winner of our
three-way ilp
poll at 86 percent of the vote 86
indiana jones people are concerned
indiana jones
come in at second place at only 10
percent of the vote with starfield
people feel more confident about that
in last place two percent of the vote i
don't care about bethesda games no more
because they not on my platform of
choice
so shout out to the messi two percent
who voted for that
and uh let's get oh alex got his camera
off i don't know if he stood there out
of your thoughts on this that people are
concerned about
indiana jones maybe i don't know i don't
really care to be honest with you
okay fair enough fair enough so let's go
to corey hell thank you shout out to the
best days the conversation has been over
you played so much man
yeah we can oh god something else we'll
come back to this like in three months
oh you're right now cory hell 15 000
chat happy
wife happy life happy husband no extra
arab extramarital loving
okay fair enough fair enough we keep it
uh but now
let's let's move on let's get solve it
out of the hot box
anyway lord king i believe you are up
this was your topic um
big march 26 show for xbox i'll frame it
for you
if you want um looks like um id at xbox
and twitch
gaming more than 100 games from
independent developers based all around
the world
they said during the showcase they'll
day update new trailers and gameplay for
more than 25 games
some including stalker 2 um hard
ascent couple others and they said that
they'll be making announcements about
independent titles coming
to xbox game pass as well community
twitch streamers will host a showcase
and conduct
interviews with developers take fan
questions and even drop some code so
that's the big one and i know you wanted
to tie that in as well
i believe with e3 so lord king the floor
is yours about this topic would you feel
where you're at with this well i believe
that uh microsoft is starting to kick
off
their uh road to e3 much like they did
last year
uh with these shows uh from what i'm
hearing in the background i'm hearing a
show
every month leading up to the this is
what it's looking like
a big show um you know what we got last
year was uh
a month of dominance you know every
every month you know phil was uh
dropping a new freestyle for other
individuals to
get in line so um my thing was just
expectations going into the show uh what
what do we want to see do we want to see
more from the last year's uh kickoff
show remember
the last year indie show and
let's just keep it in perspective right
yeah
telling you again it's in these guys
right you know so everybody went to the
indie show looking for triple a halo
and stuff so i'm not going to see halo
infinity i should have yeah
okay yeah let's let's keep it in
perspective what are we looking for what
do we want to see most about because i
want to see more about this send
um and a couple of other games that
didn't come out last year but that was
showed at the
uh the last indie outtake uh
and i want to see uh what was that game
bright infinite
i want to see a little bit more of that
bright infinite see
what's transpiring there right if they
do a deeper dive into that
and a little bit more about these
developers that are launching into game
pass
what can i look forward to going forward
and do what we get any dates on these
games
because we got visuals last year but no
dates so this is
i brought this to you guys to see what
would you hear about it lord assemble
how are we feeling about this march 26
id at xbox indie showcase
you're not gonna get halo
think that's been i think people do
forget honestly they hear another xbox
event and like great we're going to get
triple a
just all these bangers and we're going
to get all this top news that i think
it's
it's important to realize that yeah it
is the indie showcase for
leading to the summer i think that i
think it's exciting because i think it
just
constantly keeps the momentum and the
conversation around xbox even if there
is
one two titles that you're excited for
on the indie side
i think regard even if you're not the
conversation is still
surrounding xbox right which is what i
think they have been doing such a great
job of with the last year
lately whatever three months whatever it
is but they've been killing it lately
just with the conversation piece while
on the sony side
and they're fine they're being quiet and
they've got a couple of games that are
going to be coming out so i
i'm excited for seeing what indies are
there and if there's any that grabbed my
attention really
cause i won't play a ton of indies i'm
excited to play some of them that are on
game pass we're coming to game pass
right now yes
uh but yeah again it's just more
conversation around xbox
yeah my question to you really quickly
because
you said that you don't play a ton of
indies but you said game pass
uh you're a game pass owner yes
yes sir okay so all right now that we
established that
he almost says the whole exactly he was
going to talk to you if you were going
to be clean but um
all right so game pass does that uh
dictate if you uh purchase any indies
because after you get a chance to try
them because indies are really hit and
miss
type of things so does that dictate
your purchasing when it comes to
touching these indies
it will yeah it totally does even on the
playstation side right because i will
grab
a lot of them through playstation plus
right they come available
and yeah and that's probably the big
reasons like you said it's it's because
indie titles can either be
absolutely 10 out of 10 people love them
and then it's great i'm going to pick it
up but i i do not go and rush out and
say i'm going to go grab
three of these indie titles they kind of
look cool i'm going to i wait and game
pass i think
the positive of it for that side of is
going to be
i can play these smaller titles and try
them out
dip in dip out if i like to and then
some of them grab your attention and
like i think of i'm looking at my game
pass right now on my phone right
i'm looking at like not that it's a
small indie game but like streets of
rage
uh switcher age four yeah which is
something i'm like hey i remember the
old ones i'm like i want to try this out
and when it came out i'm like it's on
game pass it's free
and loved it and i absolutely loved it
and it's those smaller titles that i'm
like i am
really interested to go see so yeah i've
always stuck around with like if it's
built into it
through the subscription i'll go with it
there yeah i found that's where i found
dead cells
yeah that's a good one too yeah i
brought all the dlc and
i purchased the game uh just in case it
did ever leave you know game pass at
some point in time i didn't
even want to go to you know load my game
up because like i hit the store sir
but yeah definitely no doubt no doubt i
think addict's having some
camera i mean some mic issues so you'll
be back in but lord saw man
in the idx box next week march show
what's your expectation and how you
feeling about this
in conjunction with what king said the
road to e3 so
to speak on just the sort of the cadence
of how they're doing stuff
i appreciate the fact that a they're
being very upfront about what they're
going to show you
it and not show you i love the fact that
aaron will come on be like set
expectations yes
and then and then he'll lie to you a
little bit and sometimes there'll be a
bigger announcement there that yes but i
i
love when they do that though i love
that i love that and the fact that
they're building up to the big stuff
obviously in the summer right so you
start with the indies you get people
excited about that maybe give us a
couple of uh release dates
so i like the fact and i i think
actually when you think about
this this sort of partnership with
bethesda and and the fact that
you know when they had that roundtable
you realize that they were working in
conjunction as a part
as opposed to bethesda just being under
xbox they're working they're learning
from each other like they said
and it's obvious in how it feels like
xbox is we're going to ramp things up
we're going to we're going to try to get
to the point where
when we get to the summer showcase i
think it's really going to be they're
going to know how to drop the mic
something that we've sort of uh we've
accused him of yeah
yeah so i think this is a good ramp up
so in terms of what i specifically
am uh excited for um a few things
um so obviously 12 minutes again
he's giving me a release date please
give me a release date
motivated agrees with you i i i so badly
want to play that game
um better yet man people 12 minutes man
hit your boy
up let's get them let's get them codes
like it's one of the games that's been
in the indie scene besides something
like star renegades
that like i'm just like i got to get
that like yeah yeah
listen listen james mcavoy is listening
to the show absolutely absolutely hit us
up um
so we have that then we have tunic yes
tunic again if you're a zelda fan you
look at tunic and you're like
i've been seeing this for the last five
five years though yeah yeah
for whatever reason it's taken my
excitement for that game is
this has has definitely went down the
hill yeah just because it's been around
so long what was the what was the other
idea xbox game that took forever to come
out
oh it was sent or below below below
yeah yeah it took a minute it took it
really and by the time it came out the
wind was a little bit
it was out of it and then i got it then
it wasn't what i thought it was
it was really hard difficult
super difficult game and then and then
the last one that i'm saw like
like dark soul people yeah yeah they
they dropped that game because
oh i thought she was about to say i
actually ended it
yeah but that game again the excitement
because it took so long and then another
one that i'm super excited for
is stalker 2 yes
stalker like if anybody if you've played
old stalker never
heard it huge following it's so because
it's it's survival and it's fps
and it's all about so it's atmosphere
and
it's so difficult it's always like
traditionally been super difficult
um so i i want to see how they evolve
the stalker formula because obviously
if they make it just kind of like old
stalker you're going to find the crowd
for that right but if they do things to
bring more of the mainstream in and sort
of streamline some of those systems
and and make it so that it's more
accessible to people
and it doesn't come off like just like a
straight survival sim right
and it seems to look very beautiful like
from the pictures i've seen obviously i
haven't seen it moving yet but
if they can get that to a point where it
appeals to a larger crowd
i think stalker could be really huge for
xbox i really do
i think so i'm excited for that so i
really do want to see that no doubt no
doubt lord hattie you are back um
so i think xbox bought show like are you
excited or and what about in
king's point in road to e3 how you
feeling about this look man i'm
excited for this indie thing because i'm
a content creator i'm selfish 100
right now i know whatever they announced
in that in that call in that conference
or whatever they want to call it that
stream
is going to be gold for my youtube
that's what it's about
that's what it's about
so you know sure they might they might
show some
some like dirty gems next week but
like that's what 32 but guess what those
dirty gems gonna give me a few thousand
for you you know it is what it is like
you think i've reviewed nothing but you
know quality
amazing games on my youtube channel no
do you think i care to review them no
but do you think i review them
absolutely
my god oh my god you got a symbol dying
right now
there's that monster drinking get that
monster
but look man oh just get the super chat
real quick if i did i'll jump in
all right give me a second uh we got
you got eagle span 76 five dollars let
me chat king what's your thoughts on
these 720
tcl's complaining on twitter about
having to pay for a one-time fee for
dobie atmos and having dobby vision feat
we talked about this background so we're
godfathered in
and assembled said that you know um he
had to purchase i think it was like a
year or something like that a year out
or whatever
um and i didn't know this was a thing to
be honest with you guys i really did not
know it was the thing i do apologize
for you guys not being on the forefront
of this stuff early on
but you tcl dudes you know i told you a
pension and saving yeah i said i didn't
[Laughter]
you know what it is you know what it is
this is the first of all this has been
around forever right
so this is not something new and they
bring it up like it's an
xbox issue like if the only reason
samsung tv
you don't have adobe videos the only
reason that this is an issue
is because a lot of them are on
playstation they don't have that
like it's easy but you got 3d audio
listen listen like do they have adobe
atmos
so obviously obviously you're not paying
for a headset you don't even have
basically the fanboys are trying to say
their audio is better than theirs
you know you've got to pay for yours and
that's what you know why this audio
stuff has come into play right
right okay sony in the beginning put the
headset out and it was so
it's just 3d audio it's a big thing it's
so that came and gone
microsoft waited for the conversation to
die down and said here's a superior
headset
here you go and it has these features
right and then they went to look at
their features on their headset and said
we don't have it i want this yeah
and then they found out that they had to
pay for it and said microsoft is
just demanding money as somebody who
owns the pulse
headset they're talking listen to the
temperatures yes the police tempest
audio stuff is great
but like like mark cerny said this is
specifically for games
on that platform that is a bespoke thing
for them and then so it's not you can't
use it in movies really
so it's you know obviously with dolby
vision
with uh yeah atmos windows sonic and
stuff like that
all those things supporting the xbox
side the variety is there where it's
right
this is not gonna happen let me jump
into it because the other point is
and correct me if i'm wrong um solve is
that with the
temp system with this 3d audio system
that they're using
that's exclusive specific to the
peripheral to the head
headset as opposed to like a audio codec
like for example with atmos
you have that you can have in your
surround correct specifically i think
yes it's true i don't think you plug in
any old headset and you can do
you can do you know that virtual
surround right
yeah because it's part of home theater
setups as well right right okay continue
it's it's it's universal atmosphere you
know
the way to go this isn't like
where we got you and we got to mold it
to your earlobes
this is for everyone you know you can
partake too you didn't partake early on
when it was free now you got to pay a
fee
this is what happens when you're late
see before you can get
you can get into the club free before
11.
king's club clubhouse clearly
clearly it's 1105.
anyway what you going to address what
you got to
i think there's a lot of new people in
the chat that haven't uh
that they haven't seen we got it off
what they have no slander no no no
it's look it's it's an inside joke
it's not meant to like affinity one that
got tcl tv he's like oh yes it is
oh my god we're not shaming you
don't listen to this man if you can pick
your tv up at the door
when you're walking out with a bag of
popcorn that's not the move don't don't
listen to this man
okay if you got a cctv it works for some
not for all
all right so it's there you get a
comforter
and some sweatpants and oh my god
pick your tv up with some raisin nets
god bless
six packs of razors i'll be done with
y'all gatorade
there's some dudes out there that will
hit up people with these nice tvs that
could do 120 frames per second right
and then they get these weird old
televisions that they got to add extra
cables to
they got to add extra wires too they got
to get a run back through
and that stuff is not necessary when you
purchase the premium exchange
okay then let me just say this that is
not the aisle
that those thoughts reflect the opinion
of one man
i will say this to you this is a
disclosure
if you think that you're gonna get the
best experience out of uh
television you can pick up on the floor
at the door
it's just for you oh my god just
everybody in the chat just just remind
king that tcl
is the best-selling tv
the majority of people don't care but
but you know
like the top 10 of the best tvs last
year that series six was one of them
right
anyway let's get back to the super chat
this is still the atmosphere yeah yeah
we just went left we went left let me
get my brothers
we went left about tcl and i know these
dudes
shout out to my bro did you buy
fertilizer
i can't it's at home when you can buy
your tv
[Music]
that was great savage anyway
get a snow blower and get your token how
do you get a tv at home depot
there's a hotel it's at the front you're
in the shopping cart
they had seven of them okay king's logic
is if you bought yo
they have seven of them like he was like
he was buying razor nets
king king's logic king's logic if you
know what we're
going to do we're going to do it moving
on time time
i'll get the next super chat get my bro
oh salute
is everywhere listening to unlocked and
they dropped the iop
name congrats to all the success lords
as always and keep the hard work going
yo salute to you brother
it's a pleasure to podcast with you the
last word i'm going to say it live you
hate when i say it it's the best
damn destiny podcast y'all never heard
please check out me and my brother
subscribe this channel
scott does good content and of course
yes
and um also if you guys are looking for
outriders coverage but boy
is the ambassador outright check him out
he's got great videos if you're getting
back in the destiny please check him out
my boy the cheetah bontes at the destiny
care fact you know what i'm saying last
word
he's not a cheetah is the cat yeah he's
not a cheater right
he don't cheat in video games yeah
with the two pounds super chat for god's
sake give me the last night and tune
again that's another one
last night i was in an auditorium when
they announced it last night and
i don't know um then we got z black
writer ten dollar super chat
happy sunday lords this atheist supports
the book of acts
you already know that we are brat with
the two dollars
no absolute lords great to see assemble
on fantastic
thank you brother absolutely we have
brad once again two dollars super chat
by tcl is in the bushes thank god
oh you got the atmos worker okay cause i
saw you call me and we was working it
out nice nice you got your atmosphere
god bless you threw away that tv
now throw away your opinions on the
playstation oh my god leave him alone
shout out to brad you know you know what
uh i said the iron lure i'm joking
i'll say that stop it then we got smitty
smith with the five dollars
it's not the same people with tcos king
oh yes it is that's my turn
that was a funny story
that's exactly what it is then we have
the everborn saga
with the five dollars oh salute i do i
paid my 15 for adobe atmos back when i
got my astro 850s perhaps you get what
you pay for the book of
x facts bx stand up
love it i got my asteroid 50s like i
said to you guys before
it was yeah last year and i love my
headset
and yeah it came with like two years of
dolby atmos
and i love it and i got the i got the um
the base station as well and rigged it
to work with the playstation on my ps5
nice so i could just drop the headsets
in either one because i was like i need
a sony headset and then i realized i
could do that but
yeah on the xbox side and throwing in
avengers yeah
that on the dolby and you can go and
change the equalizers and everything
it's a different experience it's
different man i remember the first time
i heard the 850s and i was like oh my
god yeah
it's different you don't get that with
the tcl headset
oh
for a jog with those things you know how
i knew that
most things was like real real because
me and me and um
john were playing uh battlegrounds it
was when they first came out
i'll never forget it i was at the top of
the of the school and you know there's
like a staircase going all the way down
to the first floor
and john doesn't have it john has some
tcl stuff
wow we're sitting in this room
and i remember i'll never forget i was
like john they're coming up the stairs
he's like
i don't what are you talking about and
i'm literally hearing them
like rotate around the staircase coming
up every staircase
and i was like i was like i'm telling
you just aim down the stairs
you got to play we got to play the
multiverse today like yo the outside
they're using gadgets
i've literally i've literally been right
beside someone like
thermiting a wall and it scares you
right there his face is right there
shoot his face
okay then we have alvin with the 10
super chat
games like souls and stalker will lose
what makes them special if you make them
more accessible lord sob
you lose the sense of accomplishment
it's how we got 2017 justice league
it's how we got to 20 great show i i
will say this
uh what i mean by accessible is not
making it easier
right but there's some quality of life
improvements that i think especially
when you talk about the game coming to
console right
right um it's gonna you're gonna have
eyes on that game
that aren't people that necessarily play
on pc with where that
stalker lives right um i want it to stay
hardcore
yes but i don't want it to just die on
xbox okay
that's my work i've always had the
mentality when it comes to the hard
games like
if the developers want to put in some
easier mode i don't really care
like and this is coming from someone
that plays almost all of them you could
think of like
yeah like i don't think it's gonna
devalue the core experience of the game
if once the game's done they're like
let's let's put a mode where you take
more it takes more health to kill you
like i don't think that i don't think
that exists i think people
like to to put like a false reality i
saw
a controlled developer just uh mention
that same thing
you know because a lot of people worry
ending the game but then when you have
the
the the auto aim and one hit kills and
stuff like that
they notice that more people were ending
their game and getting to uh different
parts of the game like 20 hours in where
sometimes
people will stop playing if it gets too
difficult for a certain demographic of
people they would just move on to the
next game because you know the
attention spans are like that now yeah
you know
so yeah i i think that is you know some
people i like it hard pause you know put
it there
more super chat we got a lot come on
yeah we got a lot uh we got 108 with the
two dollar super chat tcl tv is coming
bubble wrap on a plastic crate
fast savage
savagery we got uh adam mass with the
two pounds super chat xcode going 1080p
with series x blades yes that is that is
great then we have flame with the two
dollar super chat you pay extra for the
best which is why i got a c10
yes sir c10 not the best but that's fine
don't be disrespectful dudes is really
trying to
save 500 bucks just pay the 500 bucks
because you're going to pay the 500
bucks and wires
so just get a better television so uh um
oh we got plenty more we got cowboys fan
of four or five dollars super chat
every tcl tv comes with a twenty dollar
instacart coupon
get your groceries and your tcl that's
right
i had to get a pack of gum at the end of
the checkout to make it look weird
because i got broccoli and a tcl
oh
are you done then you just put a tv
right now yeah yeah
it's like the tcl is an impulse buy
the giveaway and what you what you can
do to make it look all nice you put the
tv in the middle like stack the
groceries around there
yo i'm done with y'all i'm done with you
you know the girl at the checkout when
she's like
do you want the item of the week which
is like the superhero tcl of the week
thank you i appreciate it
this does not reflect the opinions of
all the
moving on we have clutch man five dollar
super chat
uh my super chat works again love the
xbox headset
and locked in on the next one my cousin
uh pleasure uh
pleasure mystic to the best podcast on
the planet thank you so much
then we have stitched two dollars the
switch light has better
resolution than tco oh my god
yo we gonna lose that spot it's over
then we got lord nader with the five
dollar chat my cousin asked for a good
tv first playstation 5
i tell him to buy a tcf wow they got
variable residents like your cousin
you know so you don't like your cousin
you know what's going to be
the true testing ground for king
king loki sold out for uh for those
statues man you gotta get rid of all the
dc statues
that's what tcl pulled up and here's the
bag
i'm talking about a big mac say nice
stuff
if they give me the mini led that can
actually do 125
oh did the slayer go stop and and they
actually stepped a bezel game up and put
it in the box
put it in a box yeah and actually i can
go to the back and get my tail tell me
please bring my tco from the back not
off the door yeah not on the floor
i'm just shaming the floor purchases you
know this this is the difference like i
see you guys all the time
i go inside the best buy and i talk to
the guy and i'm like yo um did the
new television come in from uh the ces
show
oh yes mr johnson um we have your order
thank you
okay cool ship it to my house thank you
have a nice day and i go and you pay you
know how you you know real people pay
and leave and they don't take anything
with them
right right now when you go in there you
were like oh the tcl
900 yeah nobody nobody goes into the tcl
they don't call ahead to best buy and
say hey do you have any more of the tcr
could you hold one for me
oh we have 1700
[Music]
can i buy this tcl tv and they give you
directions to another warehouse i'm done
we'll be going we are we have a lot of
people we got a lot of sweet chests we
have rap once again with the two dollar
super jack king my series x came with a
bag of mulch
yeah that's nice but you got one
i thought you wasn't getting it i
thought you had a powerful pc
leave him alone don't come for me
he's going to be he's going to be able
to plant his flowers and watch
tco at the same time he got that mode so
he can bury that playstation
time more super chats then we got
eaglespan76 thank you boss i appreciate
it
salute to atmos adobe vision the book of
acts
x z black rider 5 super chat need to set
you straight xbox atmos works with
any headset it's simulated at most yes i
don't know who said otherwise
yes yeah yeah it's just whatever you buy
it for
yeah that heads because there are
certain headsets that are more capable
of doing it than others no doubt
continue then we have abba with the five
dollar super attack
in insider programs for xbox series sx
are testing games with dolby vision yes
somebody asked jason ronald this
question a few weeks back yes ah talk
your tux off
your tuck baby the games they're testing
so far
are uh what bo3 yeah lens three
borderlands three
uh gears five reckless and halo master
chief collection yep i'm mad i don't
have the update continue
nice that's yeah i think that's like
ring one or something like that um
then we got the wise old gamer two
dollar super chat can i get dobby atmos
on my miracle ear hearing
savage you probably got it already
probably dude
apparently tcl hands out medical
licenses the docs who almost killed me
must have gotten their doctorate from
tco oh my god
nice check from tcl but remember you you
got to buy a tc or tv it's going to have
vitamins taped on the side of it
[Laughter]
fun speculation five dollars super chat
oh my god great content lord it's great
to see matt on here thank you for
shouting out his government name
not only is he a great creator he is
also a great supporter of the community
respect thank you so much
hello matt
government oh hold on we gotta jump i
know we smitty smith
they're clowning what's up he's using
his superhero needs to put his glasses
on
yeah you see me squinting right it's
about that time sweetie smith two
dollars super jack well damn assemblers
out here destroying tcl
yeah that's my guy mm-hmm then we have
108 dragons two dozen
ilp will be the reason no more tcl
celebration right
then we if you bury a ps5 in mulch do
you get our dna
there's just there's just no way the
amount of time that
tco is is slandered on the show
that some community
[Music]
yeah look the id i xbox you know soon to
do that man because um let's say chris
charles in the team
um really good to see because remember
y'all like in the beginning of the
xbox one gen yeah xbox wasn't in
the space correctly there was a lot of
issues with devs there were a lot of
issues
getting indies over and sony was in
pocket they had the you know the result
guns they had
the greater relationship the more
commitment to indies you know kind of
thing so it's good to see
you know xbox kind of now be dominant in
the space and again
12 minutes i want to see ascent stalker
two
i mean they made a statement i think
about what specifically is going to be
seen but i think it's still going to
show that there
um look they just been on fire it's been
i think just
as a whole as a week you know and
leading up to e3 what king is talking
about
it's just been positive news after
positive news
and it's really good to see they just
been on this nice
stretch you know we had the you know the
outriders news you know smart delivery
stuff with the uh marvel avengers came
out you know now we got this so it feels
like every month now we're getting into
this cadence
and the last thing i said it really
looks bright because to king's point
with e3
you know we'll have most likely now the
microsoft event but there's the
operating as that separate entity like a
extra e3 like the next day so
it's going to be a lot of content it's a
slam dunk it's a great thing i think
it's
gonna have like a third party thing like
they did last year that's a good
question right because they had they had
the third party
game
i don't think i really don't think
they're gonna make the same mistakes
yeah i don't think so
especially with bethesda's team their
marketing team
uh pitching in yes because
aaron losey aaron lewis ain't having
havoc
both both aaron's there yes i think they
will work in a
in a batman robin typically association
and they will
uh fix whatever issues like you know
i think aaron our original aaron for us
so far
you know will bring heart because i
he really cares right right and i think
new aaron
will bring that punch you know um you
know the double team aaron
double dose of aaron over there you guys
hear me yeah
yeah yeah yeah i'm you know cause my my
youtube is frozen oh no you gucci
um nah was gonna say though king you
onto something bro i i was literally
gonna say it because
the underrated aspect of the deal and my
opinion with zenimax bethesda
is one thing we've always preached from
the high heavens we go on to every
almost every three that we can
and we always say bethesda puts on the
best
show either we look forward to the but
that's the conference physically
we're upset if we don't get we upset if
we don't get in if you don't get it
man you know what i'm saying cause you
know what time it is you know what's
popping they know how to think and i
think what you said is perfect
their marketing team and the way they
celebrate stuff
to be now integrated into mike to help
microsoft because let's be honest we
always be like microsoft what's up the
marketing sometimes that's the problem
right it'd be hit and miss they know how
to sell the fight they got that flare
right and they know how to do the mic
drop they know how to
do this well i i think they
helped with that but that's that that's
the round
yes and the video
i mean you don't even really need to
look too much past the fact that
pete hines is the one hosting it yeah
clearly that was his people that
and i don't know obviously they both
could have came together but the way it
seemed
like me pete himes was hosting it felt
like that was his no
i'm just talking about that video that
the one minute and 20 second
uh video of the uh like the yeah
together i think they helped out a lot
with that because
bethesda's like intro videos or promo
videos for games
yeah they they get the buzz popping man
yeah
no no absolutely and i think like i said
that to me
will help transition into e3 and again
i'm just excited
and again i wish my brother was here
dizzy because we were talking about this
is that our only fear was like we didn't
want them
to merge into one thing where it's just
too much news it's too much on one day
right now it's almost like you're
getting two shows you know what's that
so that's the part you don't say we need
to talk about it it was just lit because
you know i'm just excited i i think it's
a perfect marriage they've
they've had the relationship from way
back you know what i'm saying since
mormon and all that stuff
and overall point with this thing i
think this is a good stepping stone with
the
again keep expectations to check it's
gonna be indie games only but we're just
getting more xbox news
[Music]
assemble only was going to give us an
hour yes please i mean like
like shoot us out like get
just shaking it on the table
yeah we have um the wise old gamer once
again 2.00
did adam cut his beard using a razor
from tcl
oh my god because i just trimmed
it i didn't shave the the edges thank
you for your edge
comment for the details that break your
face well no no like like
my beard just grows so fast like
literally like it's already starting to
come back already
i would steal his beard energy
[Music]
so i've got the glasses be ready let's
go yeah i can i can see again
oh then we have rocker corey five dollar
super chat you guys are so funny
i laughed so hard my coffee almost
snorted out of my nose
[Music]
yeah i heard them tcls can come with our
dna
yeah that's the extra audio made at the
playstation so
if you take your playstation 5 and you
put it with a tcl
you get our dna minus one
moving on then we have evan with the ten
dollar super chat sony bought evo since
they won't have games to announce at the
events have to fill by sega and capcom
at least their android phones can run
xcloud maybe nadella will buy some pity
ads
that's actually the next topic yes
yeah we're caught up all right let's get
into it quick it is so look man
so we got the big announcement you know
what i'm saying sony
buying evo you know what i'm saying so
um yeah this was this went across the
interwebs
says the sony grammar statement that
today we're thrilled to announce the
next chapter in the story of playstation
evo
the world's longest and longest largest
and longest running fighting game
tournament
they said sony interactive entertainment
teamed up with rts to acquire evo
through a joint
venture partnership so um basically they
talk about the co-founders
tom and tony cannon they remain closely
involved in an advisory role to ensure
evo continues to service the fighting
team community and then also some
statements in reference to basically the
history what was going on with evil
which i didn't know
which was um obviously because of you
know kova they were forced to haul
in person competition last year um the
organization's makeup event evo online
was then
shut down for allegations of sexual
misconduct which i did not know
thank you i had no idea this went on
kind of crazy yeah so um you know
basically before the announcement the
future of evo was
in flux and then other statements was
made in reference to
i guess there was some concern that you
know when um
sony purchased it that you know because
it's sony that there would be
you know it wouldn't be any
multi-platform tournaments and they
actually
made a statement it would be open to
games on all platforms despite
its new playstation 10 ownership and
then they made a final
okay i'm just repeating what they said
um and they just said yeah basically
you know they realized how important
this was they want to thank everyone for
the community so
and evo said they're thrilled to work
with the teams at playstation and rts to
bring you evo
2021 online this august so more
information will follow so look
this way across the interwebs this week
there was a lot of comments
here and there about this stuff so lord
assemble
evo being saved by sony the purchase
what do you feel
about this i think it's good for evo i
mean to be purchased by sony i think it
gets the
branding behind it so he's got a ton of
fighting games and be able to kind of
own that space and narrative and i'm
thinking of
kind of like microsoft doing with
bethesda deals and all these
acquisitions and not to go there
anymore if you have but yes um really
just try to own different
spaces in different markets and i think
it's kind of a
maybe it's the only step in going down
that road of that market of going to the
fighting game market
but if sony's got that name behind it
excuse me if sony is owning that
that naming and that brand um it just
i think opens up the world more for
streaming for these events
and you're getting the large sony brand
behind it and that's going to be good
for them
and i think it's good pr and it just
broadens it again for a lot of the
fighting games that they have on the
sony side
that's a good piece that's a lot of
legacy with sony
and yeah to kind of bring them together
i think it's good for sony and yeah
because of all the allegations and what
was going on with all the misconduct
um i believe for some people like very
high up ahead evo
and where this was going on yeah i think
they got to a point
in my own speculation i would say they
got to a point where like look we can't
save we can't salvage this
uh our brand and what we have done and
all of this coming
it's not good so for sony to come in and
go let's just take it
uh made an offer and we're done yeah i
think it's kind of the best of both
worlds
no doubt no doubt well said lord addict
fighting game enthusiast you are uh what
do you feel about this
it's literally i couldn't care less
about the whole evil thing
like like when they said evo like i knew
what evil was because i'm not dumb
but you know i i remember just i i saw a
lot of people on twitter
says eva what game do they make oh my
god
jesus it's like look like
i do think that people are taking away
from it a little bit too much because
at the end of the day i do think it
would be easier to go to people like
capcom and stuff and
and work out some type you know even
full exclusivity street fighter it's
like look like
we own evo that's literally where you
shine like
like we'll give and stuff like you know
they say well we're not gonna
we're gonna do multi-platform stuff
they'll do multi-platform stuff but
sony's definitely gonna be like
okay playstation playstation playstation
playstation live yeah well they're gonna
have that
yeah well that's what i'm saying like
they're gonna do multi-plat stuff but
they're talking about
we're still gonna let the nintendo
switch and play smash like that's
literally
got no choice yeah yeah look at what i'm
saying like i i guarantee you
there'd be very little xbox stuff going
on to even well that's my favorite
remember and remember it's not
playstation welcome sony interactive
entertainment yes yeah
they operate separately yeah but sony's
still gone
but the branding like it's it's one of
those things where you're they're not
going to be able to get away with like
it's only playstation they can't
no no no i understand what you're saying
but we're going to keep that same energy
uh like like we do we're not going to
separate what i've noticed on twitter
is people like to separate microsoft
from max box and we we're not doing that
no more
okay we're going to keep your companies
as a whole
we're not doing that that's right we're
not doing it
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna do
it so that it fits my narrative
listen listen you know what true bosses
do they skew it so it'll look right for
them
i feel anyway so we we're going to allow
y'all to have this
playstation purchase and y'all y'all got
that your son you got that
[Laughter]
it was dead right you brought something
dead so
evil to me is dead right now like uh
nobody went because they had to be shut
down
so you brought something on the cheap
you saw something on the floor like a
tcl
let me get back
i think they probably bought check for
for pennies on the dollar
yes they did when it's coming down
to it let's be real here like they can
use that to elevate the playstation but
what happens if this happens can i talk
yeah but i'm just saying like what
happens if this happens
what happens if microsoft actually buys
capcom and street fighter is a
xbox exclusive how how does your evo
smells then
i just like like tcl i get that but like
unless that's already been made i don't
see that happening now like
like i don't see capcom i don't see who
makes tekken
oh namco i don't see navcon i don't make
i don't see any head-to-head fighter
even being marketed by my xbox now
because like at the end of the day like
like yeah because look they're
highlighted right
he's running they want to go to evo they
want to be huge presence of evo
and if they're being marketed by
microsoft even and this is the thing
you're gonna look at them a little bit
none of these games even
what's weird about this purchase is that
they had they had that cachet already if
you look at the vast majority of games
that are played at evo apart from you
know when killer instinct was there
apart from smash
they're played on playstation content
consoles yeah that's true so
this is kind of like a technicality
right like they so now it's just a
matter of the branding is going to be
playstation
and like alex said yeah i think it
i in our chat when we first heard about
this i made the joke like oh they bought
fighting games
because that's what they did they bought
fighting games they bought they did
all of the buzz around fighting games is
not going to be
sony buzz person when when sony goes
to capcom when sony goes to namco and
they were like look we're interested in
marking your game
uh like they could do something
microsoft can't do now it's like we
could put a huge focus
at evo like literally they're they're
they're pinnacle
like that that's what all of them want
to do because if they're
big at evo it's probably going to lead
to sales more in the next game
and i i just see that happening i see
you know i could totally see now 100
not 100 like 70 chance that the next
street fighter might be exclusive
because
at the end of the day xbox has been
losing that market and i don't
do that market but i've been told they
used to have it yeah but but now it's
just like now they're never gonna get it
like a hundred percent
unless they cut they're gonna have to
come out with killer instinct 2
and smash that out the part before they
even
hopefully try to grab the head-to-head
fighter your point on on street fighters
good right because you could have
if they have evo and they go look let's
beef up street fighter
at the next event and it will be like
plastered
everywhere for you and in return they
could
street fighter may not be exclusive on
the sony side but it might be a timed
exclusive or it will be exclusive dlc
or characters whatever exclusive and
it's like i said
i like i'm not saying a hundred percent
you know
i do think they can use that because i
think at the end of the day
you know people are going to care what's
going on at evo
because the fighting community is going
i see you know what happens when you
mess with people with money
this is what happens when you mess with
people with money people with money and
you give them the opening to
smash what you just did right
this is a grand opportunity all right so
phil i know you're watching as a matter
of fact let me address you properly phil
dominus maximus are really expensive
yes i know you guys really it's real
extra yeah yeah i want you
i want you to make this
so-called win feel like feces and they
suck oh my god
wow i want you to go out
and just like you said you did not like
what they did with street fighter when
they locked it out from the xbox console
and everybody was champion oh sony did a
great move because when xbox
does something like that it's a horrible
move
they locked it out xbox gamers could not
play street fighter
right i want you and santiago to walk in
there like the bosses you are
to capcom and throw the money on the
table and make sure that
that next street fighter is a game pass
exclusive
that we get the chance to partake in
this
and make evil bender need a microsoft
you know a lot of stocking with jesus
when it comes to topics i don't normally
address the chat but people are saying
oh evo is suddenly this huge talking
point not that sony bought it
but i'm not saying that you know they're
like this is huge for the playstation
brand
but the playstation brand is the go-to
for fighters
and they bought literally the king of
tournaments for fighters
absolutely like yeah look fighting is a
niche market but it's a huge niche
market
yes and the fact that they have that
they can leverage that to do anything
they want
nobody's saying that it's bethesda level
because it's not but i like that though
i like that because you know what when
meek mill and drake was
uh battling and and meek mill
dropped uh some song or whatever and
drake dropped one of these we
it was a week so i remember that no it
wasn't definitely fruit because
it was fire it was some other some baby
lotion joint
you hated it yes it was like this baby
lotion stuff is is not
what what we want to hear right and then
back to back came after that
so this is the baby lotion this is this
is you know they
microsoft did bethesda and they come
with evil like you said somebody told
you
who what does evo make like what game
does they make
this is they have to come with something
that hits the hustler motor correct us
he said the song was charged up i'm
charged
yeah it's charged up yes and it was baby
lotion stuff and
you guys stopped this evil evil is a
baby lotion
charged up but the w freestyle is gonna
come next and i'm waiting for sony's
true response
to the bethesda this is what i'm talking
about but this is nice
they got something on the cheek this is
not like but it's it's like you know i
was talking to cognito yesterday like
i don't think like do they have the
money to make a bethesda purchase
no yes that's what i'm having they
definitely have the money but
can they can they convince investors to
spend probably 50
of their liquid assets no i don't think
like they don't need to right now right
because
you can't get a ps5
but the thing is is it it's just like to
happen at the beginning of last
generation
if people keep saying they don't have to
they don't need to they don't microsoft
doesn't need to do this
sony ain't dropping nothing then guess
what that road eventually ends and then
you got bloodborne's hitting you got all
these games in
back-to-back back-to-back like right now
sony don't have to do nothing but if
they don't make
pre-meditated stuff to do stuff right
now
if they start in a year from now and
microsoft starts dropping a game every
other month
they're going to have pace about cadence
yeah i mean we talked last week about
how do they answer right and they this
week they've already shown how they're
going to answer they're going to answer
the way they always have
right second party deals yes right we
have haven coming from
jade raymond right well not the game
it's not having the
the studio she's making a game yes
anybody want to put money down on what
that kind of game that is
third person over the show oh
and then what else do we have uh we have
project atheia we have uh
fourth spoken now which we're gonna get
into they're doing they're doing what
they keep
what they always do and i get that
solved
but at the same time the one of the
biggest people they always go to is
square enix correct i mean i think we
can agree next topic
there's only so many studios making
games at scoring
it's like are they going to buy two or
three games a year from square enix
they can't the screen
look man um look at any day you know i
thought it was interesting obviously i
want to shout out my man jeff gruff shot
the game on daily i was i was hosting
and jeff gruber's on
he had the funniest tweet he goes oh
with you know what you call he says just
that jim ryan he's like
i don't care what it is just buy
something
and then he had the evil adult which i
thought was hilarious
clearly in my opinion this is not a
response thing you know saying
as much as everyone's charged it's not
charged up it's not the baby lotion
you don't get to control yourself
what kind of response this is is oh god
he goes about to go out of business
we own that market so let's buy it for
pennies on the dollar
we can use that to slide our advantage
on certain marketing deals etc etc
but this isn't going to like elevate the
playstation like they're picking up the
brand
i just don't i feel sometimes as gay as
we we actually
go we act like this is our episode tune
in next week and
somebody's going to respond
question questions yeah what came first
what came first ether chicken
first ether k first then super super
right so this is
they're super ugly this is dumb in the
lab
responding to zettabytes i love this
jeff grove is on to something
you wanted something he said yo buy
anything there's like well how about
evil i don't know what they make but get
it
listen listen i think like i said like
for them this purchase solidifies
relationships with the fighting game
community that they've already had right
um in terms of savings yeah absolutely
in terms of saving evil
is to maintain their spark in the
fighting market exactly and
and to make that narrative be all around
sony right it also once they
in terms of making money right they're
not going to really make money from this
until they can get back
into arenas yo you heard it and you
don't mind right and that's the thing
though the worst online in the business
let's talk about online right when it
comes to professional fighting games
fighting online is kind of unacceptable
right
for professional competition right
right a lot of these games don't have
what they call rollback netcode robac
netcode is the best possible scenario
you
have for fighting online right um a lot
of these games necessarily have that
right so
they're they're better roll backs thank
you
you're gonna go back
think about it
all these games have different types of
net code right and rollback has always
proved
oh you said net code netcode you said
you know what the funny thing is about
this playstation thing that
now they own evo actually we can't say
the child is bad they keep saying they
do not own evil
but then look they have a saying what
happens in evil regardless what you feel
so whatever it is like when it comes to
like microsoft a couple years bring back
killer instinct
so now microsoft got to talk to them
about bringing killer instinct to evo
right right and it's it's that thing
where like now there's the potential for
you know for for nintendo to be a client
for
uh xbox to be a client if they want to
you know come back
right this is their thing right so um
but i think at the end of the day
they really want to get back into arenas
so they can make money off of
the arena presence right um and then
after that
it's just the association where when you
think of fighting games you're gonna
think of playstation
um and it gives them another venue to
announce things yes
obviously and that you know and that's
that's sony's back not to mention they
uh
you know sony could make their own
fighting game i doubt it would happen
but but exactly they could use this as
well where's the perfect place to
announce something right
evo has always been that place where the
new techy character the combat character
comes out
you may i just finished my play that's
literally what i was going to say yeah
it's it's one of those things
like you said sorry you said great like
name and brand association
you know what i'm saying and then also
let's be real they're saving the
fighting community it is a niche market
like
attic is saying it's i'm not when i'm
not going to sit here cap like oh it's
the greatest mom even though it's one of
my favorites it's near and dear to me
you know i'm saying i grew up on
fighters i grew up on that mortal kombat
the street fighter that tekken
you know i'm saying so i'm glad it's not
going away so to see them
partner what happened no i looked at we
had two
uh dislikes and i noticed somebody took
their dislike away oh salute
oh no he put it back right now because
you start talking
you started talking tcl and then it went
left he put it back
right now oh my bad my bad let me give
us three
okay anyway so like i said you know that
was that and then um
you know again i didn't know about the
scandal i didn't know
obviously i know about before yeah yeah
it's all now just keep talking
you know so like i was saying
at the end of the day you know it's
great to have that association i also
saw the data on something like i said as
far as um presence and
mind share right because when they're
gonna be playing them fighting games
you know what i'm saying you're gonna
have that playstation you're gonna see
you know what i'm saying you're gonna
you know well look
they only got one color so you're gonna
see that white oh my god
look look at the effect that happens
when they're gonna get some new colors
let's talk about that
let's start look at the effect that
happened with with call of duty how many
years
exactly when mike microsoft lost the
call of duty
marketing licenses that it took before
they deemed that a playstation
right it almost feels like an exclusive
and we know about the street fighter
stuff and all that look
at the end of the day and the only the
only fanboy i think i would say king
ain't gonna like this
but i do feel the playstation control as
far as the
d-pad is superior for fighting games
now this uh this is not it's not going
to say that's right
now this is it for the fps now i got
that hold on for fps is this
but for the fighting no but i do i do
have to say this because i just
uh downloaded the street fighter 30 yeah
let's go let's go collection
edition um i just had to put you know it
was a statue on the line when i was uh
fighting this dude
and uh shout out to microsoft for giving
me the best controller in the business
to beat the brakes off this dude
like a cigarette absolutely i mean i'm
not gonna say that you know because when
i was using that playstation
uh clunky controller i lost so i don't
care for the controller
in the fighting genre i like mine thank
you so much i like the defense
i like the responsiveness of the input
latency on the xbox so let's go there
yeah absolutely no absolutely yeah yeah
we need to get some colors up just get
the colors right so i can buy another
controller
the mindshare in terms of fighting games
has been with sony since the
ps1 like the moment we saw battle arena
torture
and tekken one and we and there was that
transition
to 3d polygons from 2d that's right like
it was
yeah it was kind of it's been a sony
thing um
we've seen inferior ports of of of
tekken on the
xbox and things like that so i it it
makes sense it makes sense i
i want to see how much money they make
from this once they're able to get
into you know in into arenas
um but at the end of the day i think
this is what they want like when you
think of fighting games you take a
playstation
yeah that's how i feel i do i do uh
before we go on the next topic i just
need
like a little announcement yeah what's
up go ahead um
i know i've seen people comment about it
um
i guess they like really liked what
being king did with the the playing
games thing
um so i i've been talking to them
briefly
you know we we do want to do like more
of a like
us play a game thing yeah but we don't
really have like
a sense of where to go with that so what
i'll probably do
is the members and the patreons you know
go into whatever form you can to those
like i think there's a community post on
members
put games in there that you would like
to see the lords play and i'm gonna play
a new game with you
and then we'll go over those games and
then what we'll do is we'll take like
the four best ones
and we'll make a poll on twitter for
everyone to choose from
please y'all vote for that new game
that's from the same people
that yeah it takes two but i kind of
want to play something that's
four like a good four players no i just
want to play with you pulse
[Music]
you know i like that relationship but
he's single player
so i don't get a chance yeah yeah
exactly so you can't exactly
but the thing is you can't have a mel
gibson relationship with saul
exactly move it up
they don't even know about that sorry we
got to move on we're late we crazy late
come on let's get to this topic second
they got pushed back
hold on guys okay
gummy bears we got we got eagle five
dollars
time no one cares here let's be real
thank you for the ego really bad because
i said the d-pad of the soviets
after 30 minutes of the topic it's
overnight
then we got jd gamer 5 chat sony bought
evo because microsoft probably did buy
capcom and wb and sony will have no good
fighting games on their platform
so sony bought evo to have something oh
my god
they swear this is the episode so then
we have
everything gaming with the four dollar
super chat it's irish carp
here looking forward to future
collaborations thank you irish carp
no there we go what away dragons the
five dollar shipping chat tcl
are cheap like those old school kung fu
slippers
that we all had back in the day slippers
sony is a partner in the evil purchase
not a sole owner yes we've reiterated
yes
thank you for correcting there we have
the wise old gamer five dollar super
chat sony thought they were buying a
samsung evo ssd
drive for the ps5 they didn't realize
evo was a tournament until it was too
late
yo yo he willing violin
[Music]
no games and broke pockets oh my god
jesus
that we have jd gabriel 5 super chat
nothing happens in a vacuum and sony
knows something hint microsoft is buying
a company
that is big in the fighting game genre
so who do the lords think it is
we don't know we'll see if you know if
it's
do not get me started on this and i know
if they purchase capcom
i know for a couple of years these games
will be cross-platform
but then when you start getting these
exclusive games it'd be nuts but if they
do
that and street fighter is only on xbox
i
literally this is another time where you
can bury your playstation
moving on yeah we got jd gamer five
dollars super chat nothing happens oh no
i got that one nene 28 5.
hard drive expansion oh my god
then we have flame two dollars with a
jack king what did tco do to you you
going
hard on it actually i i just see them in
the store and i'm trying to get out and
they blocking me it's like
keep boxing you in with the boxes yeah
you're not putting them in the white
oh my god then we have a paul afc
four pound super five pound super chat
thank you so much we appreciate it
um then we got jd gamer 10 super chat if
microsoft buys wb and capcom that's
three of the most iconic franchises in
the fighting game community
and microsoft can then create their own
evo street fighter
killer instinct mortal kombat did they
buy like some twitch something
equals fatality people bought some sort
of
uh esports team or organization or
something like that
um uh alexander dark 91 5
super chat just wait until xbox buys wb
and gives ed boone the money to make
killer instinct mortal kombat and their
own version of smash bros
i just want the wb deal so i can get
batman then you got spider-man on sony
oh my god i got batman on xbox
that's all i would want i'll be fine
with rocksteady but
they're gonna have to pay seven billion
percent yeah i know
that new arkham knights when you get to
four tickets
yes i want that it's delayed that game
so bad
then we have black ronin five dollars
with a chat drake is baby lotion
xbox is pushing t and drops infrared
whoa
that infrared oh i can't go like that
now kick that like that oh
i'm i'm a huge drake fan and your man
had a moment to shine that he back in
the bushes
reiterating again sony is co-owner now
of evil
doesn't microsoft own their own esports
company yeah we were just talking about
what did you talk about
um all right i was reading christmas
microsoft purchase potential yeah hey
there you go
oh what you gonna want to forte comment
attic wants that is that next yeah
okay um starting to advance added
question for the realm do you think
game pass ends up on the switch would it
determine that
uh nintendo first part well uh hmm
are you gonna answer this addict how do
you wait
we always say oh it'll be on switch
right right but think about
think about the the semantics of that
right
it would have to be a custom version
that doesn't have third-party games on
it correct it would only be microsoft
stuff right correct and then when you
think about it
they're not going to develop these games
individually to
function on the switch so it would have
to be xcloud extremely and
until we get to the point where xcloud
and streaming as a whole
is viable enough that that experience is
viable right
it's not really viable
no just i think that there's xbox's game
pass next play
is tvs it's smart tv yeah right yes i
think that
having to deal with like you're saying
the logistics and the nightmare of
dealing with the nintendo or dealing
with sony why go after that market when
it's easier to go to your tcl
go to your samsung and get the app on
tcl doesn't i agree i agree with someone
but to your point i
think real doesn't happen you're stupid
to your point of sample i think though
if you look at the statement by phil
when he says
places where game pass exists i think
that's the opening
that he's leaving you know open for for
sure for the majors
right so it's like if you want it then
obviously that they're going to do it
let me put something in here okay look
let's say
the switch does go uh the x cloud does
go on the switch
right like when 5g starts taking effect
and you know they incorporated 5g into
the switch
and you're able to fully play xcloud
to how they describe it you know 60
frames 100
uh 60 frames 1080p 1440p i don't know
what i'm saying do you think that the
option of the games on game pass
would deter people away from playing
less
first party nintendo games because
they're playing all the the
first party microsoft games on the on
game i don't think so because i think
you buy the nintend the branding of
everything at nintendo is like i buy it
for those games
but that's that's the standpoint now
because those games are on the switch
now i will say this you can literally
play nintendo's thinking
that might be playing if you could play
fable on the move
and you could play let's say you know
they have the ea so i mean that means
the majority of the sports games are
going to be in there
you have uh you know um okay it's like i
said like
splatoon sells the way splatoon does
because call of duty's not on that
platform battlefield's not on that
platform right
you know it's easier to sell games when
you have no competition
i i say this right until your point that
you might be right in that aspect
but and assemble might be right as well
because i believe when you purchase that
console
specifically a nintendo console
you're getting it for that mario those
those games that will
never ever show up anyplace else i feel
like if
you have game pass to your point if you
have game pass on it
i would play my switch more in between
those lows
because i don't play it now it catches
more dust than my ps5
so i feel like that's true you're right
but
i do feel like to a point a lot of
people pick up a switch
because of the poor the portability
right right
a lot of people pick up a switch for
like for like pokemon and they buy other
stuff because there's nothing else to
play on it now does it throw a wrench in
it if you're talking you made a good
point about
a next-gen switch having like say they
get to 5g
right or just bet it's just gonna it can
handle more of the online
what if a little wrench in it is if
nintendo finally releases or puts back
on a browser
[Music]
because then i can access my game pass
in my xcloud yeah
which is what the deal was with iphone
wasn't it right they had all the issues
with i can't get the app
on apple right so they had to work
around it and people were going through
the browser it could be a situation
where they're like if
nintendo doesn't want to play ball right
well if they did get a browser on there
right and you could go around that xbox
would just say here's an optimized
browser version
i think if nintendo got to the point
where they weren't filling that move
they would just disable the browser i
really feel like they would do that they
they
were listen the relationship is yeah
fairly decent right now
you know obviously what we had was the
minecraft they've had the the ori
you know what i'm saying the cuphead
they've got a relationship let me point
out one more
thing yes it's like ortega last night
i said look you know one of the reasons
that
zelda sells 30 plus million that mario
sells
20 plus million is because like those
are primarily
the only games on that platform take all
third parties like
in a realm tomorrow all third parties
off
off playstation guard war is going to
sell 40 plus million
horizon zero dawn is going to sell
40-plus bills because you think that
third parties are going to stop the
sales of
of their friends well i do i think
third-party definitely
competing because if you look at it from
a standpoint on sales
what's the num what's the top five games
sold on every platform besides
and the reason that they're not in the
third party on switch is because they're
not there
you're right it makes a huge amount of
sense
exactly what he's saying and i i do
agree with it i just
believe that nintendo's the outlier i
agree i think they really
believe they listen they have done stuff
that i just never truly believe that
they can do
so i have to see that animal on their
machine for me to
and see the data behind and that's what
i was saying yeah
we couldn't know until we don't know how
to consumers what hacked
we went into a switch diamond we got it
that was kind of nuts
look look i told him not to super chat
that i told him not to
yesterday but you went into this whole
no no no i want a point the addict said
let's move on
oh please addict made this a topic time
let's go moving on when forte you can't
act like you won
like anyway
super chat lord assembled welcome to the
realm chat time to hit that like button
then we got boogie downs ever boring
five dollar super chat shout out to new
york undercover
king does low key look like malik
all right let's keep going
oh damn listen listen that's why you see
me every so often
there we go brother you already know how
we do you know we play
and we gotta get those lips fresh fresh
fresh
excellent we have the wise old gamer two
dollars
[Laughter]
[Music]
if that's your real name that is hot
fire
i put money on wb or bandai namco
considering the elden ring teaser
uh being bought by microsoft before
capcom capcom is too picky to sell
and they're hot right now just going in
hostile takeover
yeah just run up in there put our
servers in there
and we'll pick you to sell it's just how
much they willing to sell yeah everyone
everybody has a price for the million
dollars that's right
tcl you heard that
first come out on tcl tvs yo facts
facts why is my tcl coming
back in a bag why is it a
bag he's messy
i mean yes i get it you know when is
something you can put in your shopping
cart as you can
buy as you're walking by maybe maybe you
don't want to get that
oh maybe i can't even discuss it three
dollars different type of gaming
birthday i told you bro i win
addict hashtag job done you wanna addict
next
go somewhere with that nonsense
yeah we're good we're good all right
let's go finally
the final topic four hours later dear
god
yes can't win yes all right so um solve
you all like we should just do two
topics a week
real quick thursday we had uh a square
enix presents a digital showcase of of
some upcoming games and it was a little
underwhelming except for
a few announcements uh i'm not really
gonna get into the the uh
the mobile phone stuff because that's
just not for us just cause and space
invaders ar
i guess is a thing alex um
we got avengers updates and news we got
we got a road map which i was
excited to see just because we got a
road map and
for people who are really into that game
i think that's a fair thing to expect
and want
um we got a reveal of the wakanda
expansion
and they're naming it an expansion which
is important which means it should be
when did the chat saying get to the
point all right that's the name that's
his name i love it
get to the point already that's the name
and he's like cold skip more codes
yeah he wants to free get he loves
freebies
i dropped some codes in the chat yeah
yeah he out here pocket watching that's
right
around y'all getting some codes and then
we got we got yuji naka's latest
battle in wonder world yes yeah i love
that setting the world on fire oh that's
nice
and we got a few more details on
outriders uh obviously coming to game
pass day one
what's the biggest things coming out of
this uh this uh
kind of direct style uh whatchamacallit
presentation was the fact that project
atheia
the playstation exclusive game now has
its final name it's called four spoken
and it looks pretty cool
i like the fact that we have a woman of
color as the uh
prime the protagonist in the game it
looks fantastic
early too like like we said this is what
playstation does this is what they're
going to continue to do second-party
partnerships for for exclusives they're
going to continue to do that and they're
going to be successful at doing it
because
once as you let's see is project atheia
it's another third-person game
action game is you know so that's that's
the home for that
and then beyond that we got the newest
life of strange game announced i know
cognito's gonna like this
um true colors yes and it is coming
uh it's i like the premise like it's the
fact that this
person can sort of see people's feelings
and it's represented as colors and it's
a mystery about her brother's death
and if you buy the i guess the the the
big edition whatever it is the
the uh you will get the remasters for
the original life of strange and before
the storm
yes i do want that i do like that so all
in all
kind of underwhelming you know the
project atheist stuff was cool
um the the the outrider sort of
explanation more and obviously for
people who are looking forward to
to avengers and haven't played it yet or
people who are looking to come back to
the game
um i was surprised that i didn't see a
game passing that announcement for
avengers man
i really thought that was going to be a
thing because that's the way i see that
game continuing to live
i feel you know i think in time though
with maybe in with the wakanda
joint later in the year because right
now i think let's be real like they
going for outriders probably was the
biggest was what was money
it was money yeah it was money so um
that's it nothing
nothing huge should speak of i don't
know what you guys thought about it
assemble
he's still here and alive and kids are
breathing and the kids kids are good
yeah
just
drink be married you're not my kid
you don't get water
that's what's up so the the the square
enix presents what was your thoughts on
it standouts your feelings
i mean for me it's marvel's avengers and
half the chat will probably just be like
nope
done i don't care um for me that was
that was great i love
to speak on that one because that is a
game that i do play quite a bit
to hear about like the wakanda expansion
and to actually see a
road map as you guys are saying uh i was
happy to see
that there are some issues with it still
obviously but
it's really nice to see that we had all
of the next gen updates and then
square comes out and we have a few
minutes at least dedicated to it
to show what we're going to plan to do
for the year no
dates no hard dates because i think
which is a i think it's a good thing in
my opinion because
if they because they had so many
problems i think that if they put hard
dates to say march is this
april july september and you know
october is wakanda if you don't hit the
wakanda dlc
in the year or at a specific month i
mean you're already toast with most of
the audience oh yeah yeah so i
i think that it's a good thing that they
actually have a roadmap
and um it's just good timing they lined
it up as best they could so
this is kind of their last shot i think
i think that's a big one for me i think
they sort of
and just sort of the the quietness on
spider-man for the playstation audience
was uh
i mean they said they're working on it
but the fact that it i think people
expected it to be ready fairly soon
and that's not i a lot of people like on
at least on my channel in the comments
this week and this weekend has been
no spider-man no spider-man i'm like i
know but they're
they are a year behind on their
projected road map where they were
supposed to be wakanda was already
uh hawkeye was already supposed to be
out in like whatever december
so we are a full year behind i don't
think spider-man
if they can keep the sony deal great
because
i have no idea i wonder if there was an
expiry date on that
at all i think it's from launch if if
the
at first i think they they purchased
that outright
right because to have a spider-man
swinging on the xbox console
i think sony yeah couldn't stomach it
yeah right
especially after what they built up that
uh franchise to be
on the playstation brand and it became
synonymous
with the playstation and the playstation
4 era
so to your point i don't i don't know
the details about it but i don't think
they will ever let their character uh
exist no i i think you're right king and
i i think that you're pro but i think
you're probably a year away when we're
talking in
february march to go here's spider-man
and you know what maybe it's gonna be i
like to be optimistic maybe it turns out
that they can say
instead of a hour and a half dlc here's
a four-hour spider-man p
like we've put everything into it and
we're ending it with that maybe they do
something like
that i don't actually want that negative
press though
you know i think because of uh the
outriders they're trying to have a nice
landing with that game uh because it's a
really hard market to crack and to be
successful in
um they want to do that they put out the
positive with the hawkeye
and the other dlc that was before it and
then the maestro then you have
the positives with black panther that is
coming as well
i think if you drop spider-man
right now and it's an exclusive type of
situation
it's great for the playstation market
but then
the other markets gets to rage at you i
think they want to have enough good will
like you said and they're just here you
go so it could be done right but they're
like
right now we just don't want to just
destroy we can barely we
we're getting the new current generation
to work
right and and trying to get what was 90
of their pc player base left and jumped
like after two months so you're trying
to get an audience to buy the game
or to turn it back on again that's the
first hurdle and then they're gonna go
from there
uh outriders is one like you guys have
mentioned that's one that i'm
very curious to see in the king you said
it's a very tough market
to jump into and seeing the demos and
the gameplay already i'm like
looks cool right i like how it looks and
how it seems to play
and there's a lot of dynamics for
characters but like for the most of
their skills and abilities
yeah but i worry that it from just from
what we see
that it is a very hollowed out destiny
light
there's not enough to do i worry that it
is mission jumping to be like just go to
x run into a field of guys hit him out
move on to the next checkpoint and i
worry that it's that it's got a great
shot though on game pass
yeah it's as good of a shot you're gonna
get with 17 18 million players
i think i think uh that's where it can
exist
where anthem didn't have that leg yeah
right
and i think now that uh xbox xbox uh
game pass has matured to the state that
it's in
because anthem couldn't launch before
when uh game pass wasn't as mature as it
is now right
now you you can see the data behind it
and it's more viable for this game to
get some life
are they still holding in that line that
outriders is in a service based game
like that they're kind of going away
saying hey they're not like that's the
you know they're not live service
they're very still i know but to live in
game fast it's going to be interesting
to see what happens
yeah because that's the expectation
isn't that like the expectation anybody
who plays that game
it just feels like that's what it is and
you know even though you say oh we have
a 30-hour campaign you can start and
finish and that's it
um they've been dying on this short
they've been it might be something
actually let's see
later yeah we'll see i mean i'll jump in
real quick um yeah look
what's that joint um king there's a war
going on outside the marv
you know what i said you can run you can
look there's a war going on that to me
this whole
conference was a philosophy conference
for me
i didn't look at it as a square
conference i looked at it as these are
two companies and shout out to game one
dales i said this one
on yesterday with uh gas at asa is that
you look at the approaches sony's
sitting there and they're like okay
project i mean was it for spokane first
of all okay final fantasy 7 remake you
know what i'm saying
we're going to do this timed exclusive
thing whether it be a year
six final fantasy 16 integrated not
found remaking it like we going this is
our approach
we're going to take these titles whether
it be one year two year
right and put this joint over here where
it's anonymous with with the playstation
5.
and then you look at microsoft and it's
like okay what's the hardest joint right
now
you know what i'm saying that's good
that's the next day it's about to drop
and we've all said like we've never
seen third party aaa
day and date right so then they're going
okay
outriders you know what i'm saying and
that came together like almost like it
felt late like i i mean
yeah it felt like out of nowhere because
let's be real like
did you hear me yeah like the demo came
out
and you would think that they would have
kind of put
got people ahead on that you know what
i'm saying yeah so the demo came up i
played it i don't know if they get so
it's a good
experiment to see how that really
affects does that
make playstation users or people say hey
i'm getting it over there you know i'm
going to answer a question what's up let
me ask you a question yeah
since you said that right mm-hmm that
demo do you think it was like something
was contingent on microsoft saying yes
to see
i don't know right but i agree i know
where you're going kid cause you already
said that you are where i'm at
to me it felt last minute and it felt
like
maybe they used a demo to gauge
engagement
and interests and then see what was
going on and then they're like yo this
man is doing nothing but it seems
probably been a huge bite right and then
let's be honest to assemble's point
we all know of from square's standpoint
marvel avengers did not hit the way it
was supposed to hit for all that
investment for all that money the marvel
license
this thing was supposed to be a mega hit
with
crazy legs they are now trying to
reinvent themselves so maybe square said
to themselves like yo we can't
have another marvel avengers situation
let's put it in this base we see what
destiny is doing
we're beyond like we see their
engagement through the roof they're in
the top 10
all the time as far as games but even
top five top three right
so now let's give our new ip this great
life
with this 20 million automatically off
the rip right
game pass yes
22 now i gave you 20 to be nice
now he's 22. yeah yes
okay like i don't sound too cheap about
it now you don't sound too bad you're
just it's not like you're on the roof
you're on the road though you want to
work
i am i'm kind of horrible just keep this
updated so look at the end of the day
it's a war going on outside this is to
me
the new battle right if michael's
microsoft's gonna gauge
how this affects these third-party games
if they're going there and how much this
assembly what's your engagement you
don't say and it's a fun
it's a fun thing because so we know what
sony gonna do because we heard about it
even before the bethesda even though
before microsoft took
cinemax right we heard they were
interested in starfield at one point
you know what i i think honestly
happened now obviously i could be wrong
i don't have
access to information about game pass
stuff
i think what happened is i think that
demo came out
i think it had you know a lot of a lot
of traffic playing the demo
and i think microsoft saw that there was
mixed messaging about the demo
and there and you know i don't know who
contacted who that's what i'm putting
microsoft i know microsoft was like yo
i think they you know
you know i see that and you know they
just got destroyed by them
you destroyed you destroyed yeah you
were in the bushes yeah you were doing
good you were doing good but
that's that's probably
yes go better okay sorry sorry but
it i was just like what i think happened
is they they were able to get that
like you know pretty cheap and i think
that it's not that long i don't think
it's going to be in there for like six
months to a year
okay i think it's probably gonna be in
there in three months you know
you're paying that bread you gotta get
it because if the game doesn't minimum
if you pay if you're paying that break
you gotta get boy i think that thing
i i think that game is supposed to be
there long enough to gauge interest
and then be yanked out for people to buy
it i don't know
what you was gonna say no i just think
that it's a game
that to me you have so many like it and
where you guys are talking about like
it's mixed messaging i'm like well is it
games as a service
right is it not no it's got single
players 30 hours
it's not clear and i think i i think
what that is is they don't want
to for some reason you know we're huge
destiny fans
people that try to compete with destiny
as the games as a service
always fail so i think that they're not
trying like that game is definitely
games as a service but they're not going
to say it
they want you to play they want you to
play that vanilla campaign
and then just slowly get you get you
more stuff to play
and then like a year from now yeah it's
against the service we just didn't want
to tell anyone at the time
it gives them almost that guarantee and
whether it's three months or a year or
whatever on game pass
it's a guarantee to know that we can do
maybe a lot better and get way more
exposure because for me
writers is not a game that i'm going to
turn around on my playstation and buy
dave thank you i'm not because it's it's
it's time it's mind share there's enough
other stuff to play
and that is coming out unless you've
been following this and you're really
eager like unless you've
got your mind on it and i want to play
that right and to you guys point
i if i got both or i have my series
s or my one x or whatever i'm gonna turn
around go yeah
i want to play it but 20 bucks yeah i'm
gonna play it over here
so i think it just it gets more exposure
to the audience immediately
and if xbox likes it and it turns into a
banger then
great then everyone wins right i mean
not to mention
that what we're seeing too is we're
seeing people
that were that had it pre-ordered on
place they should cast their own place
nation
and they're getting it on xbox that's
good
little man and cut out the middle man um
get little man to cut out the
because i'm assuming our writers is
going to have micro transactions and
stuff like that
and if if you're forcing people
they're not forced but you give them the
value of game pass over 70 dollars
they're going to pick game pass every
time and now they're on game pass by a
micro transaction so that's going
right all right all right
i feel at this point right now first i
don't think it's gonna be no three
months
that's dead and i think it's going to
stay there forever
now i know that's that's that's wishing
on the star right
king okay this is how excited for
[Laughter]
funking
it launched for you but when that patch
come out and they come out then i'm
going to say i told you so
but anyway it didn't launch on next year
so it doesn't launch to you till it goes
how i say my world works like you do
right
so it works this way it didn't launch on
next gen console
all right so i'm not gonna play that
that didn't come out i did not buy this
console for that
but i say this right i think
that game is gonna once it does its
numbers and i think it's going to do
truly well we'll be honest with you
because i see a lot of people on my
friends
are still playing the demo now talking
about maxing out their characters
because their character information
holds up when the game
actually launches so this is this is
kind of great that was a kind of uh
ingenious thing to let everybody know
that all the stuff that you're doing now
is not in vain
if you max out all your characters now
you get to try out which characters you
like the most
yes and then when the game does launch
the materials don't go over but your
experience and everything does
so now you're not starting is
i think that you know three to six
months
i think that right before it goes out of
game pass they're gonna pull like a
marvel avengers
where it's like mad cheap they're
announcing it's coming and like that
next
because that we're not getting a patch
for next [ __ ] right off the bat
right like that's putting me down the
road and i think all that's gonna happen
around the time it goes out of game pass
to encourage
the xbox people that love the game to
buy it honestly
to stay on it well just just
my my quick synopsis on the the square
thing because we're
we're going to like bushes one time
jesus listen
i thought it was great i thought sony
did a great job and
well square did a great job in uh
presenting these games and giving a name
to
some of these games and showing a little
bit more of these games in their life it
just
to be honest with you they're starting
to look the same to me okay right
they're starting to look
indistinguishable
between each other and i think sony is
gonna start to fall into that trap they
need to diversify now
they need to step back and diversify
their portfolio because a lot of these
games are starting to look the same and
i know
some sony dudes gonna be like but they
look great king
yeah but if you get the great same meal
that looks the same tastes the same
it's the same then what's what's what's
to stop you from trying other things
yeah do something different it's great
i'm going to
purchase maybe one of those games i'm
intrigued by
one of those games um
outright is great i think square had a
solid show
it just gave you a a a peek into what's
going on
but this whole thing to me was to revive
marvel
to revive marvel avengers to get that
interest back
in it so they had the other games that
you wanted to know more about but they
mainly put this here for to get this
marvel because they got to get their
money back they want their money back
for all the money
they put in that license is not cheap
yeah the license costs a lot
uh the development time that went into
it and it's a solid game they just need
to tweak some things
and to give me that wakanda that black
panther that feeling absolutely
i think for them they really need to in
terms of trying to get that money back
for avengers
yeah they they were in the red because
of avengers last year
they did they did so well with ff7
remake
and then avengers tanked them yeah and i
don't know that they ever get that back
but i do think that's what that's why my
surprise that you know obviously yes
they have
outriders now having two games from the
square enix library in
game passed at the same time is probably
a little crazy but i i thought
that was the big splash to make to be
like listen we know we need to get
people back
on board with this game um but at the
same time i realized that they did they
haven't given
the people who were there day one and
purchased that game they haven't given
them the reason
to continue to be there um and i know a
lot of people will be pissed off if all
of a sudden that game went free to play
or passed so
so i get that they're gonna have to pull
a division two
like let that that stuff like five
dollars on steam
yeah no something if you got game pass
get it for one buck
but it's real interesting what you guys
the the the sort of angle you took on it
i i it was interesting to me because it
is true
it's one company catering to two
different
audiences when you talk about xbox and
play basically
square is eating or for these two
fighting each other
with this philosophy because they're
like oh you want you want first bacon
you want you want final fantasy reggae
you got to panic arms to both stuff yeah
it did
there's an oh oh xbox yeah you want
outriders
okay you give me that bag and i'll give
it to you day and day square
is eating like they are playing both
sides so well you know what's funny
i could totally see square in like
meetings with microsoft and sony
where they're like look man it's like
that final fantasy 7 a remake ain't
nothing i can do but what i could do for
you
oh you want us to you want us to extend
that integra i mean
bill asked us to put final fantasies
full of videos
i can see uh i can see the square in a
meeting with tony
and they're like uh you know we want
this and that's like well you know we
just made exclusive uh we just put up
brought the
octopath travel low-key
i forgot about that like they are
playing this so
cause remember sony doesn't have right
octopath traveler
i believe sony did nintendo had it for
and now it's xbox
one pc yeah oh man this isn't
interesting my money back
no doubt yo shout out to the
that buy this merchandise man we want to
see you guys with them right now they do
they be throwing it up they've been
through i'll be tweeting
[Music]
appreciate that um michael aka best ice
finest five dollar super chat
just stopping by to say hello and join
my vacation in orlando with no
kids god bless say less
then we have douglas lowe with the 10
super chap i stand by my 75 inch tcl
with its table from krieger
even though my uh series x will never go
near it
i was like sony evil deal after hearing
xbox bethesda
i think we're good we good all right
cool man let's get up out of here the
poll
new uh iop poll and it's actually up on
loads of gaming.net
right now so go check that out um
to the question with the oh we got
another one yeah we got one more from
mass wreck
thanks for the great show guys that's
the only way i'm gonna say that
thanks for the great show guys coming
from the sixth
oh he throw this six oh he's from here
we go that's right
dracula had a civil life for the city
bro i'm only saying your name like that
wow disrespectful anyway yo the new
lords of gary down there pulls up man
with the latest
square edicts presents event revealing
for spoken as a ps5 console exclusive
and outriders is launching day
date and game pass which strategy do you
prefer
heading into the next generation choices
are a for spoken exclusivity
make gamers buy the console
b outriders in game pass make
gamers subscribe to your service or c
it's all fun and games until switch
locks down my favorite exclusive at 720p
those are the choices rock the vote when
it goes up
lord assemble rocking with us for 15
hours at a podcast
just neglecting his children but staying
in the room
and rocking with us
an absolute pleasure and hold on oh no
no before i get ready but we got
how do i get ready but yo where can i
find people
find you what you got going on sir first
of all thank you for having me i had a
blast like i seriously did i had a
really good time
clearly because i'm like i can't go i'm
not gonna go with those people
so i had a really great time uh if
anybody's interested at all
you can go to youtube.com assemble show
because it's all nerdy content every
single day of the week
covering games marvel dc justice league
all of that
launch my patreon patreon.com assemble
show for exclusive content the one piece
that i'm excited to
have up there by next week actually is
i'm doing retrospective
uh cartoon series covering things
starting off with like x-men the
animated series
season one giving patrons a deep dive
look at
the show overview fire fast characters
and season one and going just nitty
gritty
deep into that oh that's fire all the
stuff that we love as a kid
called you do gi joe and transformers i
will oh
my god
um assemble show
one word yes sir yes sir yes sir
assemble with the explanation point is
your youtube channel that's the youtube
channel yeah yeah assemble with the
explanation point
and then show no no yeah okay
oh it's just assembling yeah someone
just put explanation point you'll find
it on youtube continuously that's what
i'm gonna talk to
and then yeah just twitter.com assemble
underscore
show if you guys want to hang out talk
to me there but yeah there's nerdy
content
every single day of the week and guys
thank you so much for having me this is
absolutely
pleasure you know i want to give a
special shout out to our mods in the
chat
no i was just wanting to say you know i
appreciate all the mods uh
i don't check that chat anymore but you
guys you guys keep it toxic for me
we'll talk to you yeah thank you marge
you guys are fighting me i see you you
guys are in there cutting heads off
getting crazy
i see you i see you you know what i'm
saying so anyway addict can you talk to
the people about where you can
they can find you i i can't talk right
now all right cool you're in about your
favorite
back to the business thanks everyone
playing that game with me later no doubt
solve we're gonna be people no no now i
can
uh you can you can catch me i think that
game comes off the end of the month king
yeah i mean you can buy it we good i'm
down with that if it's not a side game
pass
it's certain games only one of you has
to buy it only one of you has to buy it
okay so i had to go buy it that's coming
out of the iop factory
exactly right we playing for the channel
good to have you
soft uh yeah no doubt assemble uh
amazing content man i i just
i love the fact that you you realize
that we're like long form and you feel
the same way you just want to talk about
what you want to talk about and
we could have talked about uh justice
league the whole damn show
justice league watching it on your tcl
exactly
you definitely have a new fan in me so
thank you for rocking with us too
it's the difficult thing for you to stay
three hours oh man you know you know
what i'm about to go
next week no doubt lord king with an
hour and 30 minutes worth of tcl slander
throughout this entire podcast
hijacking where can i find people find
yourself if they wanted to stop
drop the bag anyway i definitely want to
say assemble
oh thank you i mean not since nintendo
guru
god bless your soul has somebody popped
on and i've seen
his background and said yeah
like like like like really
yeah and knowing where you purchase
stuff from but looking for a little you
know
little things so uh listen like i said i
subscribe to you
yeah um your youtube i'm definitely
going to check out all that information
and remember listen guys he only had a
limited time and he rocked out the whole
time so please i want everybody that's
watching
over there man i don't watch it go over
there and subscribe and watches and
watching stuff um a true collector a
real collector he has
thought in his background and i respect
your thought in the background
there's a batgirl number one down there
not a nice
batgirl you see what i'm saying this is
what i'm talking about it was two bucks
that thing's worth like 900 bucks right
here
do me a favor uh hustle put his twitter
in the chat too
yes please please cause i'm gonna go at
him right now
um just i do appreciate your time and i
do appreciate you rocking out
and uh contributing a hundred percent
thanks man
um you guys i'm working down here so
i'm almost finished with the media room
these are placeholders that's up here
a lot of these uh cells as placeholders
and i got other statues that's gonna uh
go in there like uh for
black bolt i got medusa that's gonna be
with him and uh lock uh
black jaw um purple room is getting done
red room is almost done i'm going to do
a room tour kos
is coming i already recorded the stuff
for green goblin
i just haven't got it you know uh to
attic but uh
you guys rocking out with us it humbles
me every
time on sunday to be honest with you you
guys
are the best the the best super chats
the best
channel the best time from being from
the beginning to
400 and some change still here at the
end just to hear me talk crap uh
follow me on uh twitter uh uh king david
otw
on xbox same thing on playstation
whenever i go and recover my account is
xbox 360 level oh
one you can see me as the little monkey
icon because i want ape escape back
please somebody yell at uh sony to get
ape escape
no they they kind of shut down japan
studios so that might be a rough yeah
well microsoft go buy japan studios and
let's get it
on xbox
that's it sir okay let me just
yeah um members patreon i'm gonna be
posting that what you want us to play
keep in mind that if you're double
nipping you'll get two votes i'm sorry
but if you're double dipping that's just
how it is
uh be looking out for that i'll probably
have that up the next hour
no we didn't get a chance to talk to
cogg about his vr experience yeah no i
didn't
set
wants me to play destiny too only to
ditch me on a saturday night
yeah blame my gin shout out to right
ryan was
low-key forced to play destiny and he he
comes in the party looking to play i
don't know he you know he was in it it's
on me it's on me i messed up
i told you before stop messing with this
fraud and just kidding
i play with him stop no no no no no no
i'm going all
we're friends man i apologize it was a
trial situation that popped off and the
ign guys matched up with us
and we lost and they were talking wild
crazy and i was mad and my feelings yeah
yeah
they matched us up in trials i didn't
even know and while the match is going
on they sending messages
ha ha he he they talking wild crazy so
we lost we got smoked like a cigarette
i was mad as soon as i was mad at kai i
wouldn't get to get back
and then that turned into a three-hour
affair and i never messaged red back
until it was over that was bad that i
went to bed
i was up and i saw them playing trials
and i started playing rage yeah yeah man
i got you yeah i was i was in my friend
ran that's on me i was in my feelings
oh we will get it back um we got the
other super yes please
yeah uh before the last next super chat
uh we just wise old gamer let's give the
wise old gamer some love guys us
he wrote iron lord's podcast i have to
run medication time pray for me tomorrow
if all goes well i will no longer have
to keep
going daily to the hospital and i can
finally play some games with you so
everybody yes show some love to wisego
thank you for always coming through
brother guys i gotta i gotta jump off go
big brother
please go go go go go go go go go love
this place love you brother brother it
was a pleasure
if i could come back any
it's easier to get you on again yes yes
appreciate you brother enjoy your day
thank you
so much brother thank you thank you
don't get a tcle
then we have oh i was missing this today
lord roughness
super chat great show with standard
lords green
team green is killing it no doubt and
then we got
john g with the five dollar super chat
shout out to rand because of him in xbox
two
i found the funniest podcast i've ever
heard at work absolutely thank you
brother
salute to ram man he always shows love
his good friend even though he slandered
me
he's a good friend look again assemble
much love it was it was fantastic the
man rocked out with us but he was only
supposed to be here for an hour
so we love and appreciate that we got
the poll anybody else got the
announcements before we get up on out of
here because that's
all i got but um look more fun stuff
big stuff playing in the realm trust me
y'all y'all like it it's lit
that's all i got with this note we outta
here peace
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
oh